Oh shit, my car is still here, sorry.
Give me a sec, I'm driving over to Marvel Rivals right now.
Just heading over to Marvel Rivals.
Don't worry, just parking my car over to Marvel Rivals, everyone.
Wow, here we are.
I'm at my stop, let me get out of my car.
Let me just get out of my car.
Wow, here I am.
The Tokimobile is real.
Alright, sorry, I gotta park my car.
But we're here.
We made it to our destination.
Back at it again at Marvel.
And that's how you improv, guys.
That's when you know that I am a professional.
Give me a sec, let me make sure.
I think I forgot to do something.
I'm like, oh yeah, I forgot to change my audio.
Okay, this should be right.
Alright, so today we're gonna be practicing for Twitch Rivals.
Because if you guys didn't know, on Saturday, I will be participating.
I'm a captain for the Marvel Rivals Twitch Rivals, which is a tournament.
I know I keep saying it a lot.
I feel like I've said this like 20 times already.
Since I revealed it last week.
But I'm gonna be practicing today.
I feel like I haven't played yet.
Okay, that's a lie, because I played on an alt account with Valkyrie, Shoto, SK, Foolish, and them.
Because they asked me to join them on an alt account, so I did play a little bit.
But I didn't, but I can't say it.
I didn't play on my main for at least a day and a half.
And it's crazy.
I dropped from top 30 to like 200 within a day and a half.
People grind so fucking much, guys.
Like, in a day and a half, I literally dropped 100 plus ranks.
Like, I'm right here.
I just, I didn't play for a day and a half.
And I dropped 100 plus rating.
It's crazy.
People grind this game so fucking much, guys.
Oh my god.
Yeah, rest in peace me, Rip Bozo.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh, who does it?
Uh, no.
You invite me because I'm lazy.
I don't like being party leader.
I like to be invited.
I like to be a guest.
I don't like to be the leader here, even though I'm captain for my Twitch Rivals team.
To be fair, I delegated it multiple... I am not playing.
I refuse to play... Okay, there you go.
I was gonna be like, I refuse to play EU.
Guys, I don't... It's just not fair.
I play on one ping, guys.
It's just not fair.
I just think that like, I just want matches to be fair.
And like, you know, I don't wanna play... I don't know.
Just one ping is just not fair to people.
It's just not fair.
But yes, I won't be doing a super long stream today.
Because like, I'm tired.
I don't wanna drink GamerSups right now.
I really do not wanna drink GamerSups at the moment.
So I will not be doing a super long stream today.
So I'm just gonna be... I'm gonna be chilling a little bit.
Oh my gosh, that's not the right one.
Oh my gosh, where's the other image?
Where's the... Where's my overlay image?
I'm supposed to have two pictures.
Where's the other one?
Did I fuck it up?
Oh, no.
No, I did not.
No, no way.
Okay, maybe like this.
Is that the right one?
I know I have one that's... No, that's not the right...
What happened to my other picture?
I had two.
Where's the second picture?
Oh, wait.
Okay, sorry, guys.
I'm a little special today.
Oh, where's the other picture?
Where did it go?
Wait a minute.
Where is it?
Oh, my other picture is gone and I don't know what to do.
Where did it go?
I had two pictures.
I had two... Oh, fuck it.
I don't want to deal with you.
I feel like I fucked up the overlay.
I must have.
Oh my gosh.
Knowing me, I definitely fucked up the overlay.
Did I delete it?
Oh, I must have accidentally... I had to do it again?
Oh, I have to do more work.
I have to do above... I have to do more than the bare minimum.
God damn it.
Oh, it's so sad, guys.
A streamer that has to do more than the bare minimum.
That's the saddest thing I've ever heard today.
But yes, anyway, I'm not drinking gamer subs today because I need to chill.
I feel like lately, my body has been like...
Oh, you're going to play Marvel Rivals?
It's time to chug down some gamer subs.
I need to stop doing that because it's like...
I used to not drink caffeine, but ever since Marvel Rivals, I'm not sure yet.
I've talked about it earlier on stream, but I need more trial runs.
I need a bigger sample pool to figure this out, the scientific method and everything.
I'm trying to make sure I don't do that all the time so I'm not tired.
Every time before Marvel Rivals, I'm like, oh, I'm so tired.
I'm so tired.
The only way to fix it is if I drink gamer subs.
So now my body is like, oh, you're so tired.
It's Marvel Rivals time?
Oh, man, you're so tired, Doki.
But I'm like, am I really tired or is my body just going through withdrawals right now?
Because they're like, this is the only way.
This is the only way she'll drink gamer subs if she plays.
So we gotta make her tired so she drinks that gamer juice.
I'm like, no, Doki, you gotta stop doing that.
You gotta be strong.
So that's why today's not going to be a super long stream.
I'm going to stream not that long today and I might chill a little bit, talk to you guys a little bit after post-stream and that's really it.
Also, I don't really know if I actually have drops.
I might have just lied on my stream.
People who are like, oh my god, drops?
I don't know.
I never actually checked.
I just put it on my title because I see...
Oh, I do thank god because I never checked.
I was like, I don't know if I do have drops.
No!
Oh no, I spilled a bit of my coffee.
I'm going to wipe that up real quick.
I trust my team to do bad.
I did drink coffee earlier today because I was very tired.
I drank coffee today because I was like, let's see if my body is okay.
Because I was like, you know, coffee might not be as bad.
I was like, let's see if my body is okay by not drinking.
Who's talking?
I don't know.
Good question.
Also, I haven't warmed up at all.
This is literally my first game, so we'll see how this goes.
Am I streaming like 2-3 hours today?
Because I did have a very long stream already trying to fucking make a car.
I don't know how Finland is one of the happiest countries in the world.
After today, I don't understand.
Or like, unless they're like, they've always been like, unhappy.
Unless like, no, they've been trained.
They've been happy, too happy that they made something to make them unhappy.
Because they're like, I don't know how it feels to be unhappy.
Let me make this game to see what real pain is like.
Like, this is what I expected from Germany.
Like, the simulator games, this is what I expected from Germany.
I didn't expect this type of game from the Finns.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
I have not warmed up at all, so like, we'll see how it goes.
And yesterday, I mostly played DPS yesterday, so like, I don't feel so...
If I don't play after a day, I feel rusty.
And also, I have a million excuses, so if I do bad, I'm giving you guys a million excuses so you guys can go in with zero expectations.
Because you'll be like, oh yeah, she did tell us this and that and this and that.
Like, and this and that.
So maybe she's just, you know, she's not warmed up in all that stuff, you know?
And I'm like, yeah, that's definitely it.
I'm like, scared playing here.
I'm gonna fucking get down.
Oh my god, I can't get out!
Goodbye!
Stop!
Oh my god, I feel so rusty.
I do feel really rusty right now.
Yeah, I feel incredibly rusty at the moment.
Oh my god.
She's gonna be... oh no, she's alive.
Nope, she's alive.
You're still alive.
You're so healthy.
It's alright.
It's okay.
What's he gonna do?
Shoot me through that?
No, he is trying to shoot...
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Where's my team?
Why is it just me and my...
Oh my god.
Oh, we went to their spawn.
Did we go to their spawn?
Oh, we went to... why the fuck?
I should not have followed my cloak.
Oh my god, following my cloak was actually the worst decision of my life.
Is that bubble reaching you?
Alright, I'm a little scared.
Just a little bit.
It's okay, I can deal with one loss.
I'm a little scared though.
It's okay, I can... one loss is fine.
And then maybe two losses is fine too, you know?
Maybe two losses is fine too.
And maybe three losses is fine too.
I can regain it back off stream.
Okay, not gonna lie.
I don't trust gaining RP and gaining rank points anymore on stream.
Knowing that I'm getting... knowing that two million people want me fucking dead.
Like... I legitimately... I legitimately... I don't believe it.
I don't believe it anymore.
Okay.
Okay, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I don't think the Lay is fun.
I don't find the Lay very fun.
I feel like I rather just deal with the stream sniping and then climb off stream if I have to.
But like, I don't care too much anymore.
So like, I've accepted it.
I've accepted my life as the... It's so weird.
I've never had that experience before, being stream sniped.
Because, you know, I'm not well known on Twitch.
And I usually don't stream on Twitch too.
Because I don't get stream sniped on YouTube.
So I'm not used to this at all.
It's okay.
We're still healthy.
What's up?
Oh my god.
I am healing you.
I'm panicking, but I still healed you.
That's called a gamer move right there.
I might be panicking, but you're still getting healed.
Remember what I did.
Just remember, I have absolutely so much fear, but I still did it.
Alright, nice.
Oh yeah, there is streamer mode.
You're right.
I could put it on stream.
Yeah, but I feel like streamer mode doesn't matter when people just literally open up, like, my stream.
People who are like...
Purposely queue snipe me.
Because I know some people... Apparently, I have a target on my back.
I'm like, I'm so irrelevant.
I'm like, how do I have a target on my back?
Sometimes people queue snipe me.
I'm like, what?
Because they're like, she's Freelo.
Get her.
And I'm like, please.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I had to make a car today.
Please have mercy.
I had to fucking try to make a car.
This is my... Please have mercy.
Please have mercy.
Oh my god, the Pantyhunter has the Freelo.
Yeah, but it's more so like players who play this game every fucking day.
And then I have to do... Oh my gosh.
I have like a tech on rehearsals too.
I feel weird.
I don't even feel comfortable being back here, not gonna lie.
Like, no, no, no.
Oh, you got all.
Sorry.
That's fine.
They don't... That's fine.
It's fine, guys.
That's fine.
We don't... It's alright.
I'm so confident that we won that like I shouldn't have done it.
I was just...
Guys, I was so confident that we're gonna win this game.
I wanted the enemy team to like have a slight advantage because I feel so bad.
I'm gonna say this.
I'm gonna win this round.
I'm pretty sure.
And then we have to play a third round and we lose this game because of me.
But like, obviously, it's not because of me.
It's because my team didn't communicate better.
So like, how can it be my fault?
How can it be my fault?
Guys, my team should have communicated better.
Why did my team not communicate better?
Guys, you're never... Exactly.
Never the support's fault.
Also, I didn't think... I didn't think the cloak was gonna... I think I would have died in the cloak if I didn't ult that too.
So I was playing KDA.
Never... Exactly.
Never take accountability.
As a support player, you never have to take accountability.
Exactly.
I'm gonna make sure our fucking Strange doesn't die.
I don't know what our Strange is doing.
I just don't want him to die.
I don't... Let's just... Let's just make sure he doesn't die.
He's just slowly... Very slowly, he's just walking over.
There we go.
Alright, okay.
Okay.
I mean, you do you.
That's fine.
Alright, this is a good warm-up game.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't think they expected me to... Oh my god, please, I fell down.
Someone help me.
I've fallen and I can't get up.
I'm playing the feller.
What?
Okay, that's not my fault.
I healed you.
You all saw it.
Put the video.
I healed him through everything, so if he blames me, that's his own fault.
I did my job.
I literally... All I did was stay there.
Alright, nice.
That's huge.
Strange, get over here!
Okay, nice.
Alright, that's all that matters.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm here.
Wait, is my Strange?
Don't worry, Strange.
I'm also here.
Nice.
And he's gonna...
I knew it!
I freaking knew it!
Oh my god, what?
I am alive?
Alright, that's fine.
I mean, that's fine.
I'll take this.
I'll stay here though.
They won't know I'm here.
They'll never expect this.
They'll never expect it.
I'm just hiding in this corner.
This little Luna rat.
Where am I?
They don't know.
Alright, there you go.
See?
That was very clear.
I knew he was gonna ult there, but I had to be there to keep people alive.
We did it!
Thank you for the Twitch prom!
Thank you, thank you!
There you go.
One tricks have got to be banned.
Which one is it?
So I know it.
Oh, wait.
Which one is it?
Basics?
Spiderman one trick?
Where is he?
Yeah, this guy?
Damn.
I don't know how you can one trick in higher elo.
Like, how do you get away with that?
Like, especially when bans are a thing.
Yeah, I got him.
I wonder how.
Legitimately, I don't understand.
How long did you one trick, Luna?
Guys, I was never a one trick.
I could always play other supports.
It's just that Luna was the best character.
You can't say Spiderman is the best DPS character in this game.
Spiderman is so fucking situational, but Luna is always the best character in any matchup.
Except now.
Now, Cloak is the best, but she's still A tier.
If you have Cloak, I can still play Luna.
Yeah, but my highest win rate was actually Adam, though.
Lord, thank you for gifting a sub to Akemi.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
True somehow.
Yeah, actually, my highest win rate was actually Adam.
It was like 70%, I think.
High 70s, almost 80%.
So, I was a Luna one trick for a little bit.
For just a little bit.
Like 1% of my career in Marble Rivals.
And then I learned other characters, okay?
How you had almost... I don't know.
I don't know.
I feel like Adam, I just unlocked my fourth eye.
Cloak and Dagger, I finally unlocked my third eye, but Adam, I unlocked the fourth eye.
There's just something in him that I just... I literally became Adam.
Oh yeah, speaking of Adam, I was looking at skins and stuff, and one of my friends was saying how...
Because I was talking about Marble Rivals skins.
I'll never buy Marble Rivals skins until I get sponsored.
That's my goal.
If I ever get sponsored by Marble Rivals, I will buy a skin.
I will buy a skin.
But I was talking about some of the Marble Rivals skins, and we were judging the skins that they have.
And one of my friends was like, oh yeah, the Guardians of the Galaxy skin for Adam is so ugly.
Because it doesn't look like him.
I'm like, what do you mean?
It looks exactly like the actor.
Except for the face a little bit.
And they were like, exactly!
The face doesn't look like it.
And I'm like, of course!
Do you know how much money you have to pay to buy the actor's face?
Like,
oh my god.
Like, they have to pay like 10 plus A-list actors for their face.
Like, to copyright their face.
And yeah, the royalties would be fucking insane.
That's why they don't look like them.
Because their faces are copyrighted.
That's why some toys, if you look at toys or shows or various media, the reason why they don't look like the actors or the actresses is that you have to pay a special royalty to use their face for things.
So, obviously, this game is not gonna do that.
That's why when you hear the voices, they sort of sound like them, but not.
So it's like, you know, a copyright-free version.
So it's like, basically, they're like, oh, it sort of sounds like Tom Hiddleston's Loki, but there's just something a little off.
And so it's like, legally distinct, so the actors won't be like, wait a minute, you're stealing my voice.
They can't claim royalties off of it.
It just, it sort of sounds like them, but just a little bit different.
Yeah, they did do a great job.
Because, like, anybody can do a full impersonation of, like, some of the more famous actors and actresses.
But, like, because it's very, I won't say it's very easy, but it's, like, it's very common to do, like, impersonations.
Like, because, you know, like, Woody from Toy Story, for his voice acting, if it's not the movies, oh gosh, it's baby.
If it's not the movies, I hope he's not as toxic today.
I hope today he had a good day.
I hope he had a good day today.
Anyway, so, like, Woody in Toy Story, so y'all know Tom Hanks voices Woody in Toy Story, but only in the movies.
Only in the movies.
So everything else he's, every, all the other, like, media that Woody is in is actually voiced by his little brother.
So, like, it's not even voiced by Tom Hanks, it's done by his little brother.
So, because they're like, we don't want to pay Tom Hanks, but his little brother would do it for less money.
And obviously Tom Hanks is going to be like, how dare you, Jim?
Because he's rich as fuck, so, like, it's not like, and it's like, oh yeah, my little brother gets to be paid, you know?
So he's not going to be like, what the fuck you doing, Jim?
He's going to be like, well, little bro's trying to get the bag, you know what, let little bro get the bag.
We have Woody's younger brother.
Yeah, the money still stays in the family, at least.
Oh my god, I will fucking eat you.
I'm sorry.
I will ban the word raccoon in my chat, I fucking swear.
I will ban him.
Do it.
You know what, no, you know what, fuck you guys, I'm banning, no, I am promoting censorship of Rocket Raccoon.
That's right, I'm going into a dictatorship now.
That's fucking right, I'm banning Rocket Raccoon.
I am censoring Rocket Raccoon.
Poor Rude and Kai.
Oh, they banned Luna?
Oh, I guess it's Cloak and Dagger time.
Give me a sec.
Say your last Rocket Raccoons before it's gone forever.
Alright, where is it?
I need to remember how to ban stuff.
Give me a sec, guys.
It's been a while since I whitelisted.
Okay, block terms and phrases.
Rocket Raccoon.
There we go.
And Raccoon.
That's right, it's over for you Raccoon worshippers.
It's fucking over.
No!
Rocket Raccoon, we can never talk about him again.
That's fucking right.
You go straight to jail.
Give us freedom.
Straight to jail if I see that rodent in my chat.
Oh my god, already?
It's working already.
Crystal Raccoon, wait till you get back.
That's right.
What's stopping me from banning it in YouTube too?
That's fucking right.
What's gonna stop me?
What kind of portal is that?
That's a terrible portal.
Everything will be fine.
It's gonna be a-okay.
See?
Everything will be fine.
I feel so healthy.
You know what?
I'm going straight in.
That's fucking right.
I ain't afraid-oh wait, I'm a little afraid.
I ain't afraid of you.
There we go.
That's fine.
That sucked.
I hesitated a little bit, but now I'm confident.
I'm so confident.
I'm going crazy.
Oh yeah?
Can I ban Nemo's?
Wait, guys.
You think using pictures can save your precious raccoon?
That's right.
I'm gonna burn the emote too.
No longer are they allowed in this chat.
I'll never allow them ever again.
What the fuck?
That's right.
This is an anti-raccoon.
You know what?
Fuck it.
You guys don't get this.
You think you're gonna get this ult?
It's our ult now.
Oh shit.
Okay, I did not expect to disappear there.
Oh fuck.
Oh, I don't know where the Magneto ult is.
I actually don't know where the Magneto ult is.
I got a scare.
Legend.
Alright.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
For those who are near here, my name is Jokeybird.
And we are a very tolerant and inclusive community.
Of every bipedal creature.
True.
Don't say that.
Wait, that makes me sound so bad.
Guys, guys, guys, that actually makes me sound fucking terrible.
Wait a minute.
Guys, guys, don't listen to them.
The only thing that's like...
They're just raccoon sympathizers.
Don't listen to them.
I'm surprised like... I have zero deaths with this shit I'm saying.
I'm like literally autopiloting right now.
Oh my god.
This is a GM lobby?
Let's get out.
Let's be aggressive for once.
Oh, I'm fucking gonna suck.
That's right.
This is my... Oh, wait.
I'm a little scared.
Never mind.
I am a little scared now.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm 1 HP.
They don't know.
Everything will be okay.
I'll heal myself if I have to.
I'll heal myself.
You're so healthy!
We did it.
You're gonna what now?
Alright, free the raccoons.
Oh, thanks for giving me like the alternative spellings of raccoons, guys.
More names to add to my fucking list.
Okay, this is where I died though.
This is actually where I died.
Oh, no.
My zero deaths.
It was so perfect.
Oh, my god.
We were almost there.
That's why I'll add every single alternative spelling of Rocky Raccoon.
You think you can bypass the censorship?
You really think?
Rocky Raccoon is my favorite healer.
You really think you can bypass this?
That's fucking right.
That's right!
I'm a gamer!
I told you!
I've unlocked a third eye in this.
I told you.
There's literally a third eye.
It's actually crazy.
I figured out how to play this fucking dagger.
There you go.
I figured it out.
I locked in my Psylocke, but that's okay.
We don't need him for now.
See?
He can dash.
It's not locking him in if he can dash.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
No, Adam is my fourth eye.
Cloak and dagger is my third eye.
There's no way our Rocket is carrying.
Like, what is he doing?
What has he done?
There's no way.
I refuse to believe.
Alright.
Let me see.
Okay.
Let's get rid of this emote.
Let's get rid of Rack Attack right now.
You know what?
No.
I'm a good person.
I'll let you guys keep Rack Attack.
You know what?
I'll let you guys keep Rack Attack, but let me get all the other ones.
Let me guess.
Okay.
There's a Rodrick Raccoon.
There's Rack and Rock on Pocket Pacoon.
Rock and Raccoon.
Wack Wacoon.
Socket Pacoon.
Okay.
I give you guys that.
You guys are very creative.
Okay.
She's scared.
Quick.
10 plus Socket, Wack and Raccoon.
It's like Bendy Cabbage Patch all over again.
We created the newest Bendy Cabbage Patch.
Oh no.
I wanna say triple support is so cringe and boring, but like, who cares?
I'm winning.
That's the opinion of people who try too hard.
All I care about is winning.
I don't care about that triple support is cringe and boring.
I'm gonna win with triple support if I have- Whoa shit.
Okay.
I float over here now.
This is my new home.
Okay.
Let me get over here though.
Let's go over here.
People who say triple support is boring don't wanna win.
They're the boring ones.
You want unique comps with more exciting gameplay?
What are you?
Don't you wanna win?
Are you a loser?
You know what?
Give me four supports.
Make the sports even stronger.
Get Professor Xavier here so we can have four supports.
What fun?
Isn't winning fun enough?
You want more than that?
Or are you depressed?
Winning should be enough fun for you.
Oh shit.
He's dead though.
He's so dead.
I was not focused on anything here.
Alright.
What?!
No, I got ulted!
Wait, do I still have my ult?
No!
I got fucking strange ult.
It was gonna be so cool.
I got strange ulted in the middle of that so I lost my ult.
I got strange and armed and dangerous at the same time.
Gosha, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
We're Raccoon City now.
Rack attack.
That's fine.
I'm okay with it.
Alright, I got you.
I'll give this to them.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
That's very unfortunate for this guy.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Look, Snoopy is one of the good ones though.
Like, that doesn't count.
Like, she's my exception.
But like, Rocket Raccoon.
Rocket Raccoon.
He is not one of the good ones.
He is definitely not one of the good ones.
Snoopy lives another day.
Like, I'm... oh shit, I'm fucking goodbye.
Goodbye.
My dad... oh, no, he knows.
He knows I don't.
Holy shit, who did he chuck that to?
Who?
Oh no.
I'm a little nervous here.
So like, do you think they know?
Do you think they know I'm right here?
I don't think he does.
Oh no.
Okay, I can't do anything.
Please let me float.
Please!
Let me float away.
No!
Clueless Magneto.
Alright, I need the speed boost here.
Alright, could have lived as Raccoon.
You know what's funny?
He has the highest win rate so far in the supports.
But it's like, you don't understand.
Apparently in low ELO, everybody plays Rocket Raccoon in low ELO.
It's actually crazy from what I've heard.
Oh my god!
And he's harder to aim at.
If you play low ELO with Rocket Raccoon, because he has so much movement abilities, he's harder to kill in lower ELO because of his movement and stuff.
Yes, because he's harder to shoot at.
But in higher ELO, you have to have a third support or a really good punisher.
So like, it's just like, people rather play Cloak and Dagger, Invisible Woman, or Luna instead of Rocket Raccoon or put Rocket Raccoon as a third support.
Only because- oh my god.
Only because like...
Ahaha!
He has opened!
Fears and I!
That's right!
I told you, I don't fear no more.
I have learned what fear is.
I should ult, I have not ulted.
I usually use my ult as a counter cloak.
If they cloak up, I cloak up.
And I haven't seen a cloak ult in a while.
Maybe I'll do it here, honestly.
I won't be surprised.
I want to back up more because I feel like... Oh my god!
STRANGE GET OVER HERE!
NO!
SHE GOT PUSHED!
WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED TO DO?
HE GOT PUSHED!
OH MY GOD, HE GOT PUSHED!
ARMED AND DANGEROUS!
OH NO!
I'M ONE OF THEM!
I AM ONE OF THEM!
I told you.
I don't fear no more.
You see, if we had a triple support...
If our triple support was Mantis...
We could have got a third defensive ult, guys.
We could have had a...
Oh, look at that!
The Mantis got the third triple support.
Oh my... The Mantis ulted the third defensive ult!
I wish we had a third defensive ult.
Oh man!
Damage?
But no, that's way too silly!
That's way...
That's crazy thinking right there!
Guys, like, why would I think that?
He's too busy!
HAHAHA!
That's actually right, bitch!
You might as well not exist!
You might as well...
That's fucking right.
You're denied twice!
Twice!
Oh my god, I'm freaking out.
I might die though.
God, I can't!
Oh no, 30 seconds.
Do we have another ult?
We have- oh, it's my ult next.
Okay, we might be able to survive with my ult if we all live.
Only if we all live though.
Okay, don't worry.
I can- I have ult soon.
Okay, please do not die.
Oh my god, I just made it.
I just made it.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I actually- I actually just made it.
No, not disappear.
Not disappear.
Oh my god.
Yes!
I just- that's fine.
I'll just keep denying him.
That's right!
No longer do I fear.
No longer.
No fear when there's a third eye.
I told you guys.
I- all I do is just keep- I keep my- Just for Magneto because I know he's- I fucking learned.
I fucking hate myself.
I fucking- oh my god.
I hate this game.
I love the Marvel Rivals.
I love Marvel Rivals.
I fucking- I love Marvel Rivals so much, guys.
It's my favorite game.
I'm fearless.
I told you.
I'm fucking- I've like downloaded the game in my head now.
It's too bad.
I won't be playing Cloak and Dagger in the tournament.
I'll be on- I don't know.
It depends on the comp we're gonna do.
I'm not sure what comp we're actually doing.
But like it really depends on what the comp is because I could technically play Cloak and Dagger because of that.
What the fuck do you mean?
I out-healed him!
I even out-damaged him!
What the fuck?
I- I out-healed him!
Apparently.
Oh, okay.
Okay, apparently.
Oh, yeah.
I literally- What other abilities does he have other than left click?
I have the fucking Cloak people.
I have the DPS.
I have the- I have the blind people.
What other things does a raccoon have other than healing?
What?
Okay.
Yeah, Doki.
Oh, but Doki, how many people did you resurrect?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wow.
All right, I'm so tempted to just avoid the raccoon player.
I really am.
I- I really am so tempted.
I- I don't want to play.
I don't want to play with him anymore.
I'm just a hater.
You're just a hater.
All right.
All right, I feel really good about myself.
I feel- I feel really good.
Toxic.
Avoid all the rodents.
All right, let's see who's on my team this time.
Okay.
I hope I didn't, like, ditch one of the- um, ditch one, uh, raccoon player for the next raccoon player.
That'd be very unfortunate.
I'm gonna fucking ego you.
That's right.
I mean, I could have- I don't- I don't feel nice today.
I don't- like, I feel nice today, but I don't feel- I don't feel- what's the word?
What's the word where you don't- accommodating.
I don't feel accommodating today because I actually have to practice for Twitch Rivals.
Um, I have a tournament.
What's your excuse, Monotune?
I have a tournament in a week.
Not even a week and less than a week.
Triple support part two.
Let's go.
What?
Okay, anyway, I can't- I guess I can't play her.
Oh, I can play Cloak and Dagger though.
It's more important.
All right, I guess, um...
I guess I play Cloak and Dagger then.
I don't even know if I'm gonna be playing Cloak and Dagger, but fuck it.
All right.
I hope we do okay.
I'm aiming for top four, honestly.
Um, well, it's not really target banned.
It's more so people don't like playing with and against the Luna because nothing- because the game stops for 12 seconds.
And like, DPS and tank players get really like, ADH-pilled.
So they're like, I can't, I can't, I can't.
They're like, I need to do something.
These 12 seconds are gonna kill me.
Um, so...
So like, they just, you know, want stuff to happen.
With it not, like, have nothing happening in 12 seconds.
And Luna with Loki is really, like, frustrating because that makes it like, 24 seconds of nothing to do.
You have 20- now you would have two Luna ults and then 24 seconds of nothing.
Straight up nothing.
Nothing dying.
Nothing happening.
Is Cloak better?
Cloak is better than Mantis because Mantis feels so fucking slow now.
I think Cloak is better than Mantis now.
Her ult has better sustainability.
All right.
Let's go.
I love her.
I love her melee.
I think it's really cute.
Like the- whoa, dual flip!
Dual flip!
I think my- I don't know.
I think my positioning in Cloak definitely needs to be better though.
My positioning is not, like, the best on her.
Like, I still- I don't know what I'm- oh my god.
That scared me.
That actually scared the shit out of me because I was like, what the fuck?
What he doing there?
Oh my god, did somebody die?
Oh wait, somebody did.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No!
I'll try and use E.
I accidentally swapped instead.
All right, this is a little awkward.
This is- wait, why the fuck the Punisher one trick is on- oh my god, the Punisher one trick is on Widow?
We didn't ban Wolf?
No, we accidentally banned two Bruce Banners.
Ooh, this might be our first loss of the day.
I don't feel so good about this.
I feel like our- I don't know.
I think they're very- Whoa.
I feel they're very oppressive right now.
The DPS player is because we don't have a Raccoon.
I feel like they're- I don't- yeah, no, they're- they're- what the fuck?
I'd rather they have Punisher at this point.
Holy shit.
Wait, who needs heals?
Okay, I couldn't tell.
All right, we'll just put this in the corner.
I don't know if I want to peek because of their Widow.
Their Widow's a little scary.
Oh no.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh no, he's trying to disappear.
Oh my god.
All right, maybe- maybe we counter-disappear?
I don't- okay, let's go.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh no, he's gonna kill me.
He's gonna ki- No!
I keep forgetting.
I- oh my god.
This is my issue.
I need an ult after Fear Magneto.
I need an ult after Fear Magneto because that's like the counter to Fear.
I forgot because the other Magneto was so bad that I never had to think- like I never had to think about it.
This Mag- this Magneto knows the counter.
Knows the- Wait, what?
He knows the counter.
So I never had to like actually worry, but now I have to worry.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to the- I'm sorry to the other Magneto, but it's true.
That's literally the counter to like Cloak ult.
The Magneto just ults the fucking Cloak ult and I need to- I need to like remember that.
Jesus Christ, stop dying there.
I'm gonna die to her, aren't I?
Like stop dying there.
Now I'm gonna die to her.
Oh wait, I can do this because- no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm scared because I don't want to- oh goodbye Magneto.
Goodbye.
Unless.
I'm gonna wait until Magneto ults.
I'm actually really scared of Magneto ults.
He showed me.
He showed me that I should fear him.
He showed me that he is possibly better.
So, so I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
Oh no, I don't want to get fucking- oh shit, Berserker.
I'm saving my ult.
If I don't hear fear, I never- I never ult again.
He's- he's waiting.
He is.
Do you see that?
He's not even- he has it.
There's no way he doesn't have it.
That fucker has Magneto ult and he's waiting too.
He fucking does.
He does the counter.
He's too smart for his own good.
The mind games.
Who's gonna outmine the other?
We're playing chess right now.
These people are playing checkers.
Me and Magneto are playing fucking chess right now.
Honestly.
Time to see who has more patience.
Yeah.
Okay, it's fine.
I can wait.
I can wait forever.
And before he still kills me with his ult.
He fucking kills me in the ult and I waited for it.
It's okay.
I still have my ult if he kills me.
I did- I wouldn't have wasted my ult because I'd be dead.
Oh my god, this Magneto is not having a good time.
Look what you did.
You forced our Moon Knight onto Wolverine.
This is your fault, enemy Wolverine.
This is so your fault.
I just never stop left clicking.
This is like my strat.
Like all I do is just left click until something happens.
Alright, 61 fight.
Actually, yeah, yeah, one fight.
What's gonna happen?
Can we kite this?
Yeah, we can.
You don't have to do anything.
You can literally kite this.
I wasn't gonna waste it.
Oh my god, that's fucking right.
Oh my god, that's right.
Now it's my turn.
That's fucking right.
It's my turn.
I saw you use it.
I fucking saw you use it.
That's right.
Yeah, Magneto, I was more patient than you.
Okay, but like...
That's fucking right.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I don't know.
I think they can still touch this.
I think...
Yeah, they can still touch this, guys.
They absolutely can still touch this.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, they're touching, guys.
They're touching.
Guys, guys, they're still touching, guys.
We're in overtime.
We're in overtime and they have Berserker Rage.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I thought... Okay, I legitimately... I thought he was gonna...
Oh, I thought he was gonna be over there and then I was gonna blind him and everything, but I guess not.
Oh, no, not this up here.
Oh my god, not this up here.
Oh my god, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
I hope everything is okay.
I hope everybody is okay.
We gotta touch the point, though.
We gotta touch it.
2.50 meters.
Please.
Oh my god, I'm gonna... My turn to DPS.
It's my turn.
That's right.
I saw Magneto die.
I'm free.
I'm fucking free!
Oh my god, we're okay.
I'm free.
Nice.
He's dead.
I can do whatever I want now.
It's free real estate.
No fear.
No fucking fear.
Where's my... His name is Poopchimp.
He's... He's just... He's just a little guy.
He's just... He's just a little guy in this Marvel Rivals world.
Is he a Wolverine?
Is he actually a Wolverine?
Why the fuck was he on Moon Knight?
Also, hey, sure for it.
It was Moon Knight earlier.
Why are you solo queuing?
Go man.
Yeah, why are you solo queuing?
You got bullied off of... Yeah, he was Moon Knight at first.
Are you a game surfer?
I saw you were in the 20 minute queue in Celestia.
I was like, holy fuck.
And you were like solo Celestia too.
Like...
Yeah, but like 20... Damn, like that's crazy.
20 minute queue... 20 minute queue in solo queue.
That sounds like hell.
Sounds like fucking hell.
It wasn't... Did it go to... I heard... So I had like 17 plus minutes at one point.
Oh, it was 55!
Oh my god.
I do hear voices in my head.
That's rough, buddy.
That's fucking rough.
Holy shit.
That's good.
That's crazy though.
Congrats on top 10 solo.
That's really cool.
But 55 minutes...
That's actually... That does not sound fun at all.
Where's the other support?
I'm just gonna... I'll heal.
I guess I'll heal Magneto until something happens.
Oh, that's fine.
He's so healthy.
You're so healthy, JT.
I believe in you.
I believe in you so much.
No, that's not gonna be me.
I refuse.
I refuse to let that happen to me.
I'm just gonna keep JT up.
You guys do your thing.
I'm just...
I'm just making sure JT doesn't fucking die.
I'm barely getting like ult charge though.
Mr. JT.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'm lucky.
I thought I could...
Wait.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
You're all so fucking low.
Mr. JT.
No, don't die on me.
All right.
Don't make our Moon Knight go fucking Wolverine.
Don't make him do it.
He just wants to chill on Moon Knight.
If you don't give us the point, he's gonna do it.
He's gonna...
He's gonna fucking...
He's gonna go Wolverine.
You don't like that, Magneto?
Let us have a good time where he's gonna go Wolverine.
What the fuck am I gonna do here?
I don't want to use disappear because... I'm not disappearing, am I?
Whoa!
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm fucking dead.
I...
I'm just scared Magneto's gonna ult me the moment I do.
It's my ult.
I have to hold it.
I had to hold it.
I didn't think he'd look at me.
I was gonna be like, okay, I'm gonna float away now, but he looked at me.
That's fucked up.
How could he look at me like that?
They do.
It's Mr. Bad Boy.
He still has his ult.
Bad Boy still has his ult.
He's keeping it.
Oh, they use another support ult.
Are they also triple support?
Yeah, they are.
No fuck.
I'm having... we will only have fun if we win.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Got it.
Me and the other...
Wait, what?
Okay.
Here, Magneto.
I'm fucking waiting for you.
Look, he has it!
You know this freak has it!
You know he has it!
Oh, you don't get to use it now, you fucking freak!
That's why we're waiting for 20 years for me to use mine.
Look what happened, Magneto.
You made him turn Wolverine.
You could have used your ult and now you made Poopchimp go Wolverine.
That's lucky, right?
Now you'll never have fun.
He's on Wolverine now because he couldn't play.
Oh, yeah, you want to go again?
That's lucky, right?
Jesus Christ.
You know what?
Fuck it.
That's it!
I told you!
I fucking told you!
I got away!
I live!
That's lucky, right?
Couldn't even kill me!
Oh my god.
You deserve it.
You fucking deserve it.
I'm fucking coming over.
That was so tight.
I told you.
He literally keeps it for a while.
That was like gambling.
I literally gambled for that because I knew he was gonna ult me and I was hoping to dear god I could make it to the house.
I legitimately gambled everything for the house, guys.
The house was literally my gamble.
Okay, I'm just gonna do this until my ult's over.
It's taking over.
They have legendary too, so I'm a little scared.
I'm a little scared of the- I'm a little scared about it.
Oh my god, that's right.
I'm gonna fucking- I'm gonna DPS.
It's my turn except I need to heal my- I need to heal.
Oh, I'm fucking- I'm gonna kill you.
E Compton, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
That's all right.
Are you sure you're not a Cloak and Dagger main?
Peer Magneto.
No longer do I fear.
Another epic victory.
I did it.
I fucking learned.
Yeah, GM won.
Let's go.
I did it.
Yippee.
We're climbing.
I'm gonna- oh my gosh.
I don't know if I want to jinx it.
I don't know.
I feel like- I say that and now things are not gonna be so good for me.
Did I get- did I finally get Lord?
No, I still need- I don't even know how much I need for it.
I need like a little bit more for Lord.
What's my current leaderboard?
I'm 75.
I went from 200 to 75.
Let's fucking go.
What are you sure for?
Oh, he's right there.
You're rank 9.
This guy's almost- this guy's nipping on your- on your- on your- on your ankles right now.
He's coming to get your rank.
He's coming.
He lost.
These two are coming to get it.
I got 9 from- I was 10 before- wait, really?
You beat this guy?
Senior Huff?
You took his ELO to take- and then take his page 1?
That's so fucked.
That's- Oh, wow, you're very cute.
You did absolutely nothing and you took this man's ELO.
That's fucked, man.
That's also- that's also equally as fucked.
Just did nothing.
Not took his page.
It's free real estate.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, it's like only...
I guess like 1, 2, 3, 4...
5- 5 pages of GM1.
It's not that big of a gap, I feel like.
I'm like 75 right now.
I'm rank 75.
Top 100!
Yeah!
Two wins?
Yeah.
I- I noticed that.
I noticed that you can climb really- you- Uh, you climb really fast in the higher ELO.
And this is where I am at right now.
When is, um, schedule Doki Marvel Rivals crash out?
You see, I'm streaming- I'm streaming short today.
So there's no- no crash out today.
Is playing healer that easy?
I won't say easy.
It's just I think like...
For me, it's less stressful.
It's less stressful than playing DPS and tank because like your team doesn't rely you for kills.
They just- Playing support is literally mind games.
Like- Because like, you see like me and Magneto are just like...
We're just- we're playing chess there.
Where I was like, I won't ult if- I will never ult until you ult.
And then Magneto was like, Well, I won't ult until you ult.
And then I was like, you know, I'm gonna risk it all.
I'm gonna- let's go gambling.
I have this house behind me.
Surely he won't hit me.
And then I won the gamble.
Like, I won!
I- I don't know how I- how I lived there, but thank god the house was the strat.
Just wait, don't fear.
Yeah, it was actually- it was so scary.
I actually outplayed him.
I'm always three steps ahead.
Always three- because he knows I can cancel his ult instantly.
That's why he doesn't want to do anything.
He didn't want to use it because if I'm alive, I literally just wasted his ult with just one ability.
I just go teehee.
Wait, I dropped.
What the fuck?
Who climbed?
How dare you?
Oh no, I hope I don't- I don't- I don't drop.
I hope I don't drop.
Oh my god.
This guy was like below my rank.
If we win- oh wait, no, this guy was above me.
If we win, we take his rank.
Oh, hey, it's the Wolverine one trick again.
I'm going to ego you because I need to practice for the tournament.
I wonder if they'll have- if they'll try and ban, um, if they'll try and ban Wolverine or not.
Poop chimp versus ball.
I think I'm getting some good practice in.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm getting- oh wait, we don't have a tank player.
That's awkward.
Oh, that's so- What if we just ban every tank possible?
Oh, that's so- oh, this is- It's all right.
Our first loss, that's fine.
I- I- you know, we've been winning a lot, you know, we've been...
We've been winning a lot.
I don't mind our first loss, I guess.
I don't know.
It's all right.
Oh wait, I can snipe on and off.
Not if I ban- I know all your ults are sure for.
I'll just...
ban...
Widow.
That's fucking right, I'll do it.
I'll fucking- even if you're on my team, I'll ban Widow.
I'll waste a ban, just...
Oh, just like the last time we got in a team together.
And then we lost, but like, it was worth it.
It was so worth it.
All right, I'm good.
Oh, I'm toxic for banning the character?
Of a- of a streamer that literally said, I'm gonna snipe you on an ult and lock Black Widow.
But I'm the toxic one, I see.
I-
I'm the fucking toxic one.
All right.
Oh no.
Oh no, now he can't swap to Wolverine anymore.
No, what do we do?
Wolverine can't swap.
Oh no, this is terrible.
He can't get mad and swap to...
Wolverine.
He banned him.
Now he's fucking nerfed.
Oh, I hate this part of the map though.
This part of the map fucking- I'm like predicting where they are.
I hope he's okay.
I- I- I predicted that they're there and it was a gamble that I was willing to take.
Oh my god, can you reload though?
He's fine.
He's so healthy.
He's- How the- how much damage was this man taking?
Holy shit!
It's not fair.
They have two tank players and we have zero.
That's not fair.
What?
Wait, what the fuck am I gonna do with two- one tank player or zero tank player for one thing?
All right, guys, this is looking a little rough right now.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Guys, you know when he said I was only good at- I was only good at like Wolverine.
I think he's- I don't think he was lying.
I don't- I don't think that guy was lying.
All right, we wait.
I- I don't think it was a joke, guys.
I think he was real- I think he was serious when he said that.
I thought it was a funny hee-hee-ha-ha joke, you know?
I- No way, that'll be fine, right?
I'll use it.
Okay, there you go.
All right, let's all dance.
Oh, I fell down.
This is not good.
Oh.
No, this- Oh my god, I got- Why did you shoot it?
Why did you shoot it?
I can't hide from it!
I can't!
There was no way to hide from it.
I was like this- If you shoot the magneto, it gets stronger.
And I know for sure somebody shot the magneto because I died from it.
I refuse to believe that nobody- that that was not shot.
I refuse to believe that.
Oh, no, I'm fucking dead.
Bum-bum-bum-bum.
No!
I can't do anything!
Honestly?
I don't know.
I don't know if I should play Cloak and dagger.
I just don't think we should have a mantis.
I think it should be Luna, Cloak, and dagger.
Honestly.
I think Luna, Cloak, and dagger would actually win us this game.
Or triple support.
Oh, they're running.
Yeah, they're running triple support.
That's what I'm saying.
Mantis is not good anymore.
She's like...
Uh...
She's not...
Um...
Her...
Her cloak and dagger is just stronger.
Well, I don't play dagger or suit.
Okay.
All right, go play Luna.
You know, our other support player is...
Do you play Luna?
Luna?
Okay.
I think Luna's better here.
Yes.
Okay, swap.
Swap you, whore.
Come on, swap.
There you go.
See, I call everyone whore.
Just like this guy.
That's just like this guy.
That's right, whore.
Don't worry.
It's not...
It's not a derogative term because I call everybody whores.
Capture the mission area.
Whore, whore, whore, whore.
It's like a nickname.
Yeah, it's like a little nickname.
It's like affectionately.
All right.
I like how I've played cloak and dagger three games in a row, but I'm supposed to practice Luna because our other support is playing cloak and dagger.
Like...
Oh my god, I'm supposed to freaking practice.
Oh my god, I'm supposed to practice...
others Luna right now.
I'm not supposed to play her.
I'm not even getting practice in.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm okay with that.
Rp is more important.
It's all right.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
I think like...
I think...
Poopchamp is a really good player, but only on one character.
So like, I don't know guys.
I don't... I don't feel so good.
Oh, wait, what?
Did he miss?
Haha, what was that?
Shoot him.
That's right.
That's what happens.
You saw what happens guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, we double support ulted.
That is my bad.
I... I don't like, um...
I don't like Fantas... uh, invisible women's, um...
Ults down.
It's so hard to hear.
It's... it's really hard to hear.
I... I can never tell like, when she ults because of it.
I like... like, this appears really good.
Because it's like... but like, what was it?
Something... something shield.
Yeah, it's very hard to hear because... so like, I always get like, fucked up.
I was accidentally double support ulting her ult.
Because I could never tell when she ults it.
Because she's invisible.
Bum bum ba dum.
Bum ba dum ba dum.
I'm going... this is gonna kill me, isn't it?
I... I have a... well, never mind.
It's just gonna kill my entire team.
They still have Magneto ult.
I don't think he... I don't know if he realized I ulted.
Are you saving it for my next ult?
You're just saving it for next round.
If only we had a support ult.
If only.
Okay, but you don't know who ulted first.
It could... I could have ulted first and then she fucked up.
And I'm not gonna open up the replay.
I'm gonna go with that.
What?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Bro, what the fuck?
Just because he fucking ulted?
Okay.
Oh no.
Okay, that did not save anybody, but that's okay.
Okay, I still died.
It didn't matter.
Hey, I lived though.
Guys, I lived.
I lived from the Magneto ult.
That's all that matters.
No, I lived through the Magneto ult.
Okay.
We just realized.
Who did I avoid?
I mean, he's really good.
He's...
He's really, really good at Wolverine.
That's it.
That's it, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, now that we know he's only good at Wolverine, we can now avoid him and target ban him.
And that's just life.
Just don't be a one trick.
That's the lesson here.
Just don't be a fucking one trick.
Literally nothing else.
I like how he was so direct with us too.
He was like, I can't play anything else guys.
I'm like, oh.
Okay.
Thanks.
Okay, I guess we avoid you?
I guess.
Okay.
Thanks, bro.
At least he's... true, true.
At least he's honest.
I didn't even got here.
I don't know.
I feel like Wolverine is so target banned a lot.
That's he... I don't know how he squirmed his way in here.
Like, wait, what is his rank actually?
I'll check.
Um...
Uh, history.
Okay, there you go.
Uh, what is it?
What is this?
Oh, okay.
But I have other ways to find you, my boy.
I can find you via other ways.
Jesus.
Oh shit, wait.
Actually, I don't think I can.
Never mind.
Oh, never mind.
He actually... wait, I...
Wait, wait a minute.
What is it?
I will find you.
Oh, wait.
He actually... he covered his tracks.
God damn it.
He...
He... he covered his tracks.
I can't find him.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You're so lucky.
Would it... come on.
Give me your player UID.
No,
I don't think he's on the leaderboard.
I don't think so.
Is he?
I don't...
I don't think so.
I don't think I can get his player UID from that.
Oh, he is?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Poop.
Oh, he is!
He's ranked 159?
Oh my god.
That... I definitely dropped.
How much did I drop?
Okay, I'm still ahead.
Oh, I got out of top 100.
Poop.
Snake, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Uh...
Uh, Zai, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
You drop a lot, but you also gain a lot, too.
Uh...
I have no idea who these people are.
I got a lot of random friend requests now.
I'm sorry, I don't know who you are.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Who are you?
Wait, what?
Is this Heelys?
What the fuck?
No, no, I have him on my friends list already.
I have Doki Brite Fat.
What the fuck?
That's me.
Wait, that's me.
Imposter.
Fucking imposter.
The real Doki Brite.
That's me.
That's fucking me.
Oh, my win rate is not...
Okay, but look at this win rate, though.
Okay, but look at this win rate.
I told you.
That's the one that matters, guys.
That's... Oh, it's Frank Castle.
As long as Frank Castle gets to play Punisher, we should be fine.
Should be fine.
They don't know.
How would they know?
If it isn't the Psylocke.
Oh shit, Final Fantasy 7.
Dude, you guys are... Why'd you guys ban my Punisher?
What the hell?
Bro, your name is Frank Castle.
That's Lily Punisher's name.
I don't know how to play him.
I've never played him like once in my... You have a lord mastery.
What are you talking about?
All right, let's ban Wolverine.
I ain't here to get Wolverine.
I ain't here.
How are you scared of Storm?
I start dancing and she's irrelevant.
Frank Castle and then I go Widow.
This is not the voice I expected from a Punisher one-trick.
Oh, we forgot.
How are we getting every fucking one-trick in existence?
Why are they on my team?
Low-key?
I don't understand.
All right, here we go.
Guys, I'm changing my username.
Can someone give me two dollars so I can change my username?
I don't even know who this guy is.
Any Mantis players?
Frank does meta?
I refuse.
I NEED TO PRACTICE LUDO.
I don't care.
Bro, send this bro to...
He doesn't know how to play anything besides Widow.
He doesn't know anything but Widow.
What kind of fucking hero pool is that?
Frank, listen, listen bro.
I'll buy you a whole name change for your third sword.
I feel like you're lying to me.
Bro, send me your cash after the ride.
I only take Apple Pay.
Can I get your number?
Yeah, bro.
Is that Riz?
You see what I did there?
Yeah, yeah.
This is funny.
Sure is.
You wanna be my...
Groomy.
What?
I wish you would do me.
Wait, that's Riz.
That's Riz, chat.
That's Riz.
Yo, chat, is that Riz?
Yo, chat.
Who is he talking to?
No way.
I don't even know who he's trying to talk to.
Wait, he never even...
Why did he not go third support?!
He was willing to pay him!
He was gonna give him money!
He was actually willing to pay him money to play third support.
I don't understand.
Actually, easiest fucking money of his life.
Are you not like money?
What are we doing to this Bucky right now?
Who's gonna know?
Who's gonna fucking know?
I'm not the one that's paying him!
We were just bystanders.
Being a bystander is not a bannable offense, guys.
Wait, we got the touch.
That's sad.
We got the cap already.
Yeah, we already got the cap.
What the fuck?
We're taking some money.
Who's gonna know?
Who's gonna fucking know?
Marvel isn't even sponsoring me so I don't think they're watching anyway.
Take the money.
Oh, the...
All I'm saying is if I'm not being sponsored by Marvel Rivals I don't think they know I exist!
So who's gonna know?
Are we gonna get snitches?
You guys ain't know snitches, right?
They know.
They don't know.
They don't fucking know.
This guy needs to play.
This guy needs to fucking play.
Oh my god.
They're gonna storm ult.
Oh wait, we killed him.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, that was a little too early.
Okay, that's a little too early.
That was a little embarrassing.
He counted wrong.
It's 12 seconds of you can't do anything.
Not fucking 8.
You miscounted.
It's 12 seconds.
What rank is this?
Top 100.
Cause I'm like, I'm rank 100 and I'm rank 175 right now.
12 seconds of not having fun.
Yeah, he counted too fast.
I think I'm rank 100 and something.
120 something?
I don't remember.
I gave him $5 in gold!
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
No, you gave him $5 to fucking play triple support.
That's different.
That's so different.
Someone finally killed the Sylas.
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
Throwing?
Dude, we weren't duking it out.
Oh, there he is!
He killed him!
There he is, playing 3D chess.
Right there.
I'm not used to taking damage from a Widow.
There he is.
I told you, that's all they do.
That's all they fucking do.
He just waits.
I'm not gonna let you kill it.
He just fucking waits, I told you.
You had my other team like, my team geeking too.
They were in the chat like, do you know who this guy is?
And I was like, no.
Do you know who he is?
Does he stream?
Because I'm only afraid of streamers.
I'm only afraid of streamers.
Oh my god.
Does he stream?
I'm only afraid of streamers.
There's fucking streamers that are bad at this game.
Oh, and you're afraid of Storm.
Wow, I'm so scared.
There might be someone you'd be afraid of in this lobby right now.
Like who?
I don't know.
I'm sorry, he's right.
He can't be afraid of me when I just missed like fucking three shots there.
He's so right.
Okay,
I can't.
Yeah, goodbye.
Goodbye, I live though.
I live.
I mean, we can literally avoid him because he literally said he's a widow and he's a widow punisher one trick.
Like, good enough for me.
Like, thanks for exposing yourself there.
Oh my god, he's so low.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, he's fine.
I forgot I have a snowflake on him.
He's so healthy.
I hope that... do we have to disappear?
We don't.
Okay, this is a little bad.
Yeah, no, this is not a fight.
I'm not gonna...
What's he gonna say to Frank?
What's he gonna say?
He wanted to say something to Frank.
I did ult there because we already lost two people, so there was no reason to ult there.
I have my ult now.
There we go.
Go, Frank!
Go!
Do something!
Do something, Frank!
Kill her.
Kill her!
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's fine.
That's... I saved her!
I saved her!
Okay, we might be dead though.
We might be dead.
She's waiting.
We might be so fucking dead.
We might be dead.
But we would have lost invisible girl ult, guys.
All I'm saying, we would have lost that ult.
I did it, guys.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking... Oh, Frank is on triple support.
He's on... That's right.
Know your place, Frank.
Know your place.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright.
I'm gonna let invisible girl ult first.
I feel like...
I feel like he's a reactionary ult here.
Yeah, I'm gonna let invisible girl ult first because of it.
That's fine.
Everything will be not the best, but like it will be okay.
It's fine, Frank.
You can learn how to play Adam, I believe.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're gonna put on a...
No.
Oh my god.
I'm alive.
I... He didn't count.
He didn't count again.
He didn't fucking count.
Okay.
Please.
We have... No!
He did it!
He did it.
He didn't get invisible girl.
That's okay.
We have a portal.
Oh my god.
No.
Well,
I do, but I'm better at Psylocke.
I know how to play Storm.
Okay.
Who's gonna play Storm?
I don't know.
I don't know what she was...
I think our Sue was not having a great time.
I know how to kill her.
You better not.
Whoa.
Why don't you go invisible woman and I go whatever one of you swap off to?
I don't think we... We don't really need the invisible woman.
No, I don't think so.
Do you want a solo tank?
Yeah, we can solo tank it.
You better swap out right now.
Rowan is like, you better swap right now.
I'm like, oh my gosh, whoa.
Oh, oh, we had two.
I didn't see that.
Oh my god, okay.
We don't need a tank, guys.
We don't need a tank.
Everything will be okay.
I need to reload.
He's gonna try again.
It's gonna work this time, guys.
You don't understand.
I was watching...
I...
I think they're gonna yell at Frank again, guys.
I think.
I don't think...
I don't think Frank is gonna...
What happened to our stream?
How did he get there?
How did our stream get there?
Oh my god.
How did I bump into two, one, three, one tricks in a row?
That's actually crazy.
Like, what are the odds?
That like, high elo is very limited.
So like, it's crazy that I'm able to bump into three, one tricks in a row.
What?
Why?
I missed, I missed, but that's okay.
We'll babysit each other, right?
We're gonna babysit each other.
We are gonna babysit each other.
I'm missing my freezes, though.
It's not good.
Today's not a freeze day.
I think it's also because I played Cloak & Dagger four games in a row, and I'm not like, locked in on Luna right now.
What did they say?
Excuse me?
Let's do Invisible in Reverse, then.
Okay.
Okay, I'll use it.
Okay, okay.
Um...
I didn't think we need to use it for Mr. Fantastic of all people.
Like, oh no.
Maybe I do now.
Maybe, oh no.
Okay.
Alright.
I was gonna say, I was gonna say, I did not think we need to use Invisible for Mr. Fantastic, and I had to use mine because I was not being kept alive there.
I was like, I was gonna die.
But then everybody was so far away from me.
I thought people were gonna walk forward.
I was like, guys, I have...
Okay, Storm is gonna kill us.
She's gonna murder all three of us.
I can feel it.
This is where we die.
One of us will live.
It's not me.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Oh my god, thank god.
I thought it wasn't me.
But I was wrong.
It was me.
I get to live.
I get to...
Guys, on the cart.
Your position is garbage!
You're garbage!
You're supposed to be in the air!
You're Starlord!
Holy shit!
He has 14 deaths!
He can't say that!
Oh my god.
I'm going Storm.
You want Starlord?
No, not at all.
Starlord's fucking useless as fuck.
Starlord is useless to that.
Oh my god.
A name change won't fix you.
A name change won't fucking fix you if this is your hero pool.
He cannot be like, how am I dying when I'm next to the healers.
That's crazy.
That's a crazy statement.
Oh my.
Okay.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm going to put it on our Storm now.
Because our Storm matters more.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go!
Here we go!
Let's fucking dance!
Alright, nice.
We're okay.
It doesn't matter.
You're first.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
We're okay.
Alright, where is it gonna be?
Woah!
I feel so safe now.
Oh my god, we finally did it, guys.
We coordinated ults, guys.
I'm so proud of us.
I'm actually...
I'm so...
We fucking did it.
Kill her!
Oh my god.
Please.
Please get me in here.
Please get me into the happy juice.
Please.
The safe juice.
Let me be safe.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh no, not Mr. Fantastico.
Oh no.
I'm gonna say that and then we're gonna fucking die to it.
Know what I mean?
You want me to go now?
Oh, there it is.
Ha ha!
Ha!
That ult is so worthless.
I think he's gonna charge up.
Ha ha!
Ha!
Yeah, yeah.
You might not need it.
I swear, this has to be the most grounded um, the most grounded Starlord I've ever seen.
I don't think I've ever seen a Starlord that has not fucking moved.
Ha ha!
Oh my god.
Fucking predicted bitch!
Oh, he's still gonna die.
He's still gonna die.
I'm sorry.
Ha ha!
3, 2, 1.
I'm so dead.
He pushed me.
What do I do?
Ha ha!
That was a lot.
Yeah, like, I don't know.
He was not living that.
He was definitely not living that.
Are we on point?
I wonder if we're on point.
His last fight?
Oh, this is.
Get him.
Get him!
Oh, JK.
Let's go!
I'm avoiding this.
Ha ha!
But I did it, guys.
He's.
Did he just say, Hey, I'm him.
Alright, you know.
You know what that means.
Bro, Goofus has like, I'm him.
This shit.
Ha ha!
He played it yet.
MVP.
Ha ha!
Sure, little bro.
Sure.
Avoiding the MVP.
Ha ha!
Not great at punishing.
You don't know that.
We don't know that.
I've never seen him on Punisher.
Triple support.
Wait, we should.
I'm gonna avoid the Mr. Fantastic.
Wait.
Wait, did you avoid Mr. Fantastic?
Ha ha!
That guy's an ELO terrorist.
Whichever one it is.
I don't remember which one.
He gave you an upvote.
And you know what?
I deserve another upvote too.
Was it buttcrunch?
Ha ha!
That's right.
Tough love.
It's fucking tough love right there.
Um...
It was...
What?
Is butt censored?
But...
No.
Buttcruncher.
No, no it's not.
Ha ha!
Oh, I said muncher.
Butt muncher?
Ha ha!
Wait.
Munch.
No!
Wait.
Butt munch is censored.
If you put butt and munch together, it's censored.
Butt munch.
Ha ha!
Bro, you can't eat ass.
Eat ass.
You can't...
You can't say anything about eating ass.
Wait.
You are not allowed to munch any butts here.
Ha ha!
Bro, you can't.
Why, Liv?
Ha ha!
Why the fuck is that the case?
Guys.
Munching butts is not allowed here.
In Marvel.
That's not fair.
Why give them all this cake if we can't munch it?
What's the point?
I might as well die.
Ha ha!
Like...
He's right there.
This is unplayable.
Ha ha!
I don't understand.
They give them all this ass, but you can't munch.
Ha ha!
Cruel and unusual punishment.
Can't even eat this.
19 inches.
Ha ha!
I can't believe it.
I discovered a new censorship.
But you can name yourself Butt Muncher?
Why can't you name yourself Butt Muncher?
Oh, I'm age 3, by the way.
You can name yourself Butt Muncher, but you can't munch butt.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Oh, because he's Butt Cruncher!
Oh, never mind.
His name was Butt Cruncher.
Never mind.
I guess it's sort of...
No, he was Butt Cruncher.
Sorry, I thought his name was Butt Muncher.
The crunch is better than the munch.
That's true.
My mods make a command saying my rank, just be like...
If anybody do exclamation point rank, just write...
write...
She peaked...
She peaked rank 29.
She peaked rank 29 and ended top 500 in season 0.
There you go.
I don't want to do it myself.
That's true.
That's another good question.
Are any mods around?
Ha ha ha!
That's true.
That's another concern we have.
Do we have any mods around?
Oh my god, do I have to do my own work?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I have to do my own job.
What's the point?
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
KnightBot.
Rank.
Okay.
Exclamation point rank.
Peaked rank 29 in season 1.
Ended top 500 in season 0 on support.
Not a one trick.
Ha ha ha!
There you go.
Alright.
The mods left after I censored Raccoon.
Ha ha ha!
Alright, there you go.
I just need people to know I'm not a one trick, guys.
I just need people to know.
Oh, I should be like ended top 500, 1 above all.
1 above all in season 0.
There you go.
I'm not!
I can play Mantis now.
I just don't play her because she's not good anymore.
Thank fucking god.
I don't want to aim anymore.
Ha ha ha!
Thank fucking god.
I don't feel like aiming today.
Ha ha ha!
Whoa!
I love Mantis.
Um...
Today, I just don't feel like aiming.
I mean, aiming on Luna is so...
I can autopilot aim on Luna because Luna is...
Um... Luna's aim is hitscan.
So, it's so easy to autopilot on Luna.
Also, my tracking got so much worse now because there's no tracking support characters.
So, my tracking is so...
I used to be really, really good at tracking but I haven't done it in so long that it's pretty bad now.
Or like, just not as good as it is like as it was before.
But my hitscan improved a lot.
My hitscan improved so much more.
But Mantis is projectile.
So, it's so frustrating aiming with...
It's so frustrating aiming with Mantis and I don't have fun with it.
Because I like...
It's just frustrating.
Um...
Having nerf support specials?
No, they're still as overpowered.
Ha ha ha!
They're still...
Support ults are still overpowered.
Now, they make...
I think like the Marvel Rivals of balancing... The Marvel Rivals of balancing is so funny.
They basically do like... If every character is overpowered, then there's no need to balance anyone.
That's...
That's their strat when it comes to...
Um...
When it comes to how they balance characters... Oh my god!
That's so smart!
If every character is...
Yeah!
Oh boy!
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, so that's really how they do it.
They literally just make everybody so fucking strong.
There's like...
Everybody is so strong, they don't need to balance anything.
And everyone gets...
Yeah, everyone gets ult.
It's so easy.
People will be like, wow, how did you ult track?
Okay, this is how I think.
The NMT team's ult comes up every other fight.
So, usually they get it in the second fight.
The first fight, they build it up.
In the second fight, they either get it or they either have the ult or they get the ult.
And that's how I ult track.
And then it's just like...
If I counter ult somebody, if I have a ult, they have it.
If I'm counter ulting someone, if I defensive ult Storm ult, then if I have my ult again, then Storm has her ult.
So that's literally how you ult track.
It's like baby ult tracking.
Overwatch ult tracking is so much harder because they slow down.
It's so hard to build ults and everything.
In Marvel Rivals, everybody's the same.
The building percentage-wise is almost the same thing.
Those people were like, oh my god, how do you freaking track everything?
I'm like, it's so easy.
It's like baby's first ult tracking experience.
And that's really how I do it.
But I usually turn my brain off.
I mean, I just don't commun- Today, I don't want to talk to my team.
Usually, I would tell my team, they'll have this next time.
But today, I'm like, I don't fucking- You guys figure this out.
As long as I know what I'm ulting for, it's fine.
I'm like, I don't fucking care.
You guys do your own ult tracking.
You're on your own.
I know what my job is and that's all that matters.
Are you gonna build Synergy?
There's no Synergy to build!
What do you mean?
Who am I building Synergy for?
Oh shit.
Potentially really big game.
I'm scared.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh my god.
We're against the World- The champion 3-stack?
Oh, 3-stack.
We're against the team that won the Marvel Rivals tournament.
We're against the controller player too.
No, it's just a really good- They were just queuing at the same time.
Their game just ended.
Ooh, this is gonna be scary.
Scary.
I'm gonna get hard targeted.
I'm gonna- You might not see me alive for most of this game, guys.
I'm just gonna say.
You might not see me alive.
Alright, here we go.
I have to lock in.
Do I have to talk?
No, no.
I have to- Talk to people.
I believe.
Me too.
I believe too.
Alright, here we go.
Who is not loaded in?
Who is it?
Okay, it's Wicked.
Because I'm 100% loaded.
Okay.
That's so- Talking to people.
You're right.
I'm a lesbian.
Alright.
Oh my god, I'm a lesbian on the fucking- Hero of Black Panther?
Alright, I believe now.
Wait, do we have- No, we don't.
We don't have a support player.
Okay, this is a little awkward.
It's only me.
I'm the only support player.
Who do we ban?
Hey guys.
Ah, nobody wants- Okay, Bruce Banner.
That's fine.
I'll only believe in Wakanda if this guy changes my worldview.
And kills like everybody.
He's not real until he changes my worldview.
So it's not happening.
Guys, you're supposed to believe in my team.
I thought you guys loved Wakanda.
I didn't like Wakanda no more.
I thought you guys were gonna believe.
Oh, now you don't believe in my team.
Now you don't believe in Panther.
Oh, you're gonna ditch Wakanda now?
After all that?
I'm chill with healing.
It's okay, it's okay.
You got it.
I'll play some Chatham.
Wakanda and Zelda.
Dirty, dirty.
Alright, let's see how this goes.
I love how- I love how it's like Guru TTV.
Subtle advertisement right there.
It's so fucking tiny.
Very subtle.
I'm liking this.
Alright, here we go.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh my god.
Guys, if I- if I die, please remember me.
Alright.
By the way, apparently I found out, the person that made the video about the Luna tech and saying how there's more burst healing, lied.
I knew it was bullshit, but like, I didn't realize it was- it doesn't actually give burst healing.
Like, I was talking to the pro players and they're like, no, that's not real.
It apparently doesn't actually give burst healing.
So people did that just to kill their team.
It's actually crazy.
You're walled off.
Oh no.
You just do that, you die on the internet just like that.
Yep.
Impossible.
There's no reason.
Oh no, I have to reload.
I have to reload my hands.
Please.
Please, guys.
Do not die.
My hands need to be reloaded.
I swear to god, this Black Panther is getting so babysat.
There's no way you can die.
If you die after everything I'm doing to you, like, there's no way.
Oh my god, please, please, please.
Oh my god, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
Fear.
Oh, fear.
I can't, he used it.
Oh, nice.
Goodbye.
I have to leave.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, you're walled off.
Oh no.
Guys, it might be...
Oh, nice.
Can you...
Okay, it's fine, I'll touch it.
I guess we don't go strange, question mark.
Oh, hey.
I don't know if he's gonna live, guys.
It's okay, Groot.
Break, break, break.
It's okay.
He's so healthy.
Change his ult.
Oh my god.
He's so healthy.
He's so fucking healthy.
There's no way he can die.
Alright, here you go.
I don't even know if...
No, he has two kills.
At this point, he's living, but I don't...
At least he's not feeding.
Like, I don't know.
He's living, but okay.
Nevermind.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm gonna die here.
Oh, straight up.
Double ult.
I got ult.
Okay.
Oh no.
No.
It's fine.
I should've saved it.
I should've saved it for the rez.
I forgot about the Groot moon ult.
That was my bad.
Okay.
Don't ult.
Do not ult when Groot ults.
I need to remember that.
And then save it for the rez beacon.
Okay.
I'll do that next time.
I remembered.
Now, I've locked it in my head.
I keep forgetting they have the combo, but now that I...
Now that I know.
It's fine.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
It's in my head now.
I've downloaded it.
Okay, we gotta make sure...
I'm not giving the Black Panther.
I can't give this to the Black Panther anymore.
He is not picking up his weight.
He is, actually.
It's pretty good, though.
He's not picking up his weight.
I don't care if he lives longer.
My tanks need to live.
My tanks are more important.
Alright.
I don't care.
Groot needs to live more.
Oh.
Goodbye.
I can't.
There's no point.
I just waste my ult.
Wakana is gone.
Wakana is fucking gone.
It's over.
Am I gonna live?
I am.
Guys, I don't know, but I don't think... Oh, shit.
I was not paying attention.
I don't know, but I think, like...
I don't know.
Iron Lesbian might not be, like, the best.
I'm not sure, though.
I might need more data.
But, like, it's not looking so good for Iron Lesbian.
Iron Lesbian.
Oh, you're walled off?
Oh, man.
Okay.
I have combo.
You can look for...
Oh, my god.
I had...
No!
I'm waiting on you.
Oh, my god.
Please.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
That's not even enough damage.
Alright, I give up.
Alright.
It's fine.
We have Rez.
It's the worst that could happen.
We have... Oh, okay.
Alright.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're... Everything is fine.
Everything is fine.
Don't give up now!
What will your TTP say?
Oh, that's unlucky.
That's rough, buddy.
That's so rough.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't believe in our...
I don't believe in him.
I don't believe in our lesbian anymore.
Like...
I don't know.
Goodbye.
I accepted my death.
Every time I see myself in there, it's... I'm like...
It's alright.
It's just how it is.
It really is.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I didn't realize.
I thought it was just me.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It was just me.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, my god.
That's fine.
Don't get off it.
Oh, we got off it.
Faith lost.
Oh, my god.
He's...
He's Wakandan.
Backroot is insane?
Well, I mean their 4 stack is... Their 4 stack is basic.
Or 3 stack?
I don't know if it's 3 stack, but...
TTK, Vinny, and SJP were the champions of the tournament.
Should I still believe?
I don't know.
Every time they all... I just...
What do I do?
I like...
I just stare at the death.
Like...
No one survives the moon.
And like...
Somebody has to die to that moon.
And I guess it's me.
Our tanks die so fast.
It's so hard to sustain them.
It's not the answer?
There's nothing else.
Cloak and dagger?
You don't sustain in cloak and dagger?
I think maybe we went Luna, cloak, and dagger?
I don't know, actually.
Or defensive ults?
But defensive ults doesn't matter because the moon...
Moon combo fucks you up.
I guess the only thing that you live from is...
Oh, I guess the only thing you live from is the Adamult.
I saved my ult for Adamult.
That's the only thing I can think of.
But it's like...
But it's like... It's so difficult because they have so many...
We have to use two support ults to live through one...
Like, to live through an ult combo.
So it's like such a waste.
It's such a...
IMO, I feel like it's such a waste.
But like, there's nothing else we can do.
So that's like the worst part.
Wow!
Wowee!
Everybody is taking so much damage!
Oh my god!
Wowee!
I feel like I should...
Oh my god, please.
I have to push the cart.
Please, guys.
We only have Adam here, so I'm pushing cart.
Alright.
Freeze them.
Let me freeze...
Let me freeze them before I die.
Oh no!
Save him!
Goodbye.
Guys, I froze him!
Guys, I did it!
I fucking did it, guys!
Oh my god, I feel like I'm gonna get grilled.
I feel like...
Guys!
No!
You think I... Okay.
Freeze the moon!
I did it.
Yeah, that was... No, Vinny is a really good tank.
I think Vinny and TK are really good tank players.
I didn't use my ult because I was like...
We'll just die from...
We'll just die from combo and then I'll ult in at this point.
I don't know.
This is such a...
It's scary.
I should...
I know I should orb my flankers, but like...
They take so many...
Oh no.
No, I couldn't kill!
Why do I keep getting...
Oh, thank god.
Yeah!
Intentional!
Guys, do you guys like that?
I freezed him.
Goodbye.
I don't...
I don't win.
Oh, thank god.
Just fuck me, I guess.
I'm getting...
Fuck me.
I guess.
Just...
Just kill the Luna player.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I didn't...
It's understandable.
You know what?
It's fucking understandable.
Oh no, you're walled off!
No!
We can't save you!
Oh, that's huge!
That's huge!
Who's gonna do anything?
Oh, he's walled off still!
And I'm gonna die!
What?
There's nothing I can do.
I just get...
I just have to watch it all happen.
That's the most fucked up part.
Not the moon this time.
Are you...
Oh, sorry.
You're gonna have to die there for the sake of...
For the sake of...
Okay.
I froze him!
Guys, I did it!
I did it!
I froze him!
That's what you guys wanted me to do.
I think they chose not to do the whale anymore.
Because they were like...
They were like...
This is not fair.
And I agree.
I froze him.
Come on, please.
Please.
I swear to god.
Like...
There.
Guys, I actually did it.
I actually froze him.
Real.
Okay, I need to go closer.
I think he might actually die.
Okay.
Our lesbian is dead.
He is dead, I repeat.
He is.
Goodbye.
Wait, he didn't use the whale?
I thought he was gonna...
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna use the whale.
That's the only reason why I didn't ult.
I hate this.
This is actual hell.
This is torture.
This is the biggest mind game of my fucking life.
Oh, the one time I didn't use my ult.
He doesn't whale.
Bro, I fucking...
Oh my god.
I thought I was...
Fuck this.
I'm going in.
Goodbye!
Oh fuck, okay.
Alright, this is fine.
They commissioned me.
They did.
I'm getting mind gamed right now.
I'm getting mind gamed.
Please, I'm just...
Please, I don't scrim.
Please, stop.
Apparently, these teams scrim like five hours every day.
I'm sorry, but that sounds so miserable.
I'm sorry.
Like, five to six hours every day.
That's so...
For me, that sounds miserable.
I'm sorry.
I'm okay with playing rank.
I'm okay with rank for six hours, but I've done scrims before for Overwatch and they are so mentally draining.
Because you gotta play to the highest level every time.
And that's every day too.
It's like more...
Because you have to play as if it's a tournament every day.
That's for six hours.
I'm fucking around right now.
I'm like fucking around.
Yeah, but rank is different.
I'm literally not...
I am tryharding, but I'm not...
I'm literally talking to you guys and chilling.
So, it's like...
I'm just playing rank and hanging out with you guys.
In scrims, it's like...
Basically, you have to play at the highest level and calm and everything.
And make sure you coordinate and talk to people and everything.
And I can't do that.
Not anymore.
I'm not strong anymore for that.
I'm not strong enough.
I did that for...
I did that for Overwatch, but...
That was like years ago.
And it was so miserable.
I'm dead.
I'm fucking dead.
It's just like... I don't know what to do with that.
The eye of Agamotto.
It's okay.
What can you do?
Please, please let me at least live one more day.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I lived.
That's all that matters.
I'm pretty sure the tournament...
People... Okay, the thing I'm like really scared about...
The thing I'm like really, really scared about for the tournament is that everybody is gonna be like...
Everyone is gonna be practicing the Groot-Moon Knight combo.
Cause it's such...
It's such an easy win condition.
It's so frustrating.
It's whoever team is the better...
Moon Knight... Groot Knight player.
Cause it's such an easy combo to coordinate.
And then... But then you ban Groot.
Then like...
You're wasting a ban slot.
And that's the worst part.
Like...
You're like...
You have to waste the void slots too.
And I'm fucking...
And I know a lot of teams... A lot of teams are practicing with Groot...
With Groot-Moon Knight.
So I feel like a lot of...
If you don't ban Groot or Moon Knight a lot of teams in the Twitch rivals are gonna run that shit.
Like it's... It's not gonna be fun!
Oh my god!
That's like the most unfun comp to play against.
Cause it's such a fucking mind game.
Like...
Cause nothing can...
Nothing can fucking...
Counter that.
Um...
Bum-bum-ba-dum.
Yeah, they're gonna exploit the hell out of it.
They are.
100%.
Um...
It's just frustrating.
That's like one of the most frustrating...
It's one of the most frustrating...
Um...
Combos they have.
I don't think there's a combo that's even...
There's a combo that's like worse than that.
Yeah, yeah.
You have to ban Groot.
You don't ban Moon Knight.
You have to ban Groot cause you don't...
But then Namor is so fucking dumb to play with.
To play against too.
Um...
I hate playing against Namor.
Because they buffed him.
Buffed his slow.
And it's so frustrating.
That's what I'm saying!
This is how they balance the game.
Just make everything so fucking strong.
Makes me hate everything.
Who's my team in the tournament?
Um... I posted on my schedule.
But it's me, Ryamazing, Gomez, Super Gomez, Hogs.
Three of them are from the Nightmares roster.
So me, Ryamazing, Super Gomez, Hogs, um... Coney, and uh...
I think her name is Sabubu.
Um... So me and Sabu are the support.
Uh...
Gomez and Ryamazing are the DPS.
Hogs and Coney are the tank players.
And we're trying to...
We're trying to get a... We're trying to organize a scrim this week before...
Uh...
We're trying to organize a scrim with one of the other...
One or two of the other teams.
Uh... For the uh...
Before the tournament because we haven't played together yet.
So like I want to be able to play against one of the teams.
I want to play with my team to uh...
To like coordinate.
Like make sure our chemistry is okay.
Also, okay so like...
I was going to talk about this.
I avoid every MrFantastic player.
That's people who are trying to force MrFantastic especially in this ELO.
Because like...
Uh... MrFantastic is so dog shit.
And like...
There's a streamer that's doing like bronze to GM.
And they're trying to do it on every character.
And every other character he's done was so easy for him.
So he would get like...
It would be like 60 to 5.
Like 60 wins to 5.
And then he's trying to do MrFantastic now.
And then it's at 80 to... It was like 83 wins and 82 losses.
Like I think they've been stuck on...
I think they've been stuck on MrFantastic for 4 days now.
Since launch.
Since...
Like every other character has been like...
1 to 2 days.
And I think he's...
I've never seen that record before.
And I think that like explains how fucked up...
I don't think MrFantastic is a good character.
Like...
No, his ult is just... His ult is literally a worse Bucky!
It's... Oh my god.
Like it's literally a worse version of Bucky.
But like...
It's not even unlimited.
His ult is like a limited version of Bucky.
Cause you can only do it 6 times max I think.
While Bucky, you can again forever.
But he's so fantastic though.
He's so...
He's so fantastic.
If he's so fantastic...
Then... Why do I see invisible women with...
Why do I see...
I don't think I should finish that sentence.
Hey... Whoa there buddy.
For those who don't know...
Alright.
In the early books...
I literally... Okay.
In the early books before Sue married Reed.
There was a big contention between Reed and Sue because she was in love with Namor and Reed.
And wasn't sure which one she wanted to be with her.
To be with.
Okay.
So they have...
They have history.
Namor was always...
I mean like he's running around in his underwear like...
Oh my god.
Not again.
We have to do this all over again.
I...
I'd be so down for that honestly.
Why don't we just ban Groot?
I'm so sick of Moon Knight already.
Alright.
Oh triple support.
Let's fucking go.
Namor was always a master creep.
Like he was a full-blown your body... Wait.
Wait.
Whoa.
Whoa Namor.
Perfect.
We have triple support.
With the... Okay.
Wait.
But they ban Wolverine.
Oh shit.
Cool.
I'll watch the Hulk ban here.
I told you.
Whoa.
Alright.
Double shield.
Triple support.
And then I'll know our third DPS.
Or our first... Our only DPS.
XO.
Thank you for the twitch prime.
Thank you.
Oh.
Does he think they're stream sniping?
Is that why he isn't picking a character yet?
Is that it?
That's...
Their enemy Loki is the only Loki in this game with better stats.
Whoa.
He's better what than what?
There's no streamers poking through.
He's got better damage.
Oh.
I'm really tough to say something but I'll be nice.
Say it.
Come on.
It's for me.
I'm not going to ult first.
I'm going to hold my ult.
Actually I don't know.
Actually I don't know if I should.
I don't know if I should ult first or not.
I don't know.
I thought the same thing too but I didn't want to talk.
That's a little awkward guys.
I should have said something but I'm just a bystander.
I'm part of the problem.
I'm just a bystander.
The bystander effect is going on strong.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh, same guy.
Same guy.
Oh.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
This is awkward.
This is so awkward.
Three Ludas.
Oh my god.
They have too many kill ults here.
Which is scary.
Wait, they're the same stack.
They literally got the same team.
What the fuck?
How did they get the same team?
Three stalling ults I guess.
Jesus Christ.
Our Groot is never gonna live.
Oh my god.
Please.
It's alright, we have this, right?
Alright, nice.
Let's all dance.
They have so many...
You guys are so dead.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
You guys are so dead.
They have so many game ending ults.
Again?
Oh my god.
I can't dance anymore.
Please.
I don't wanna dance no more.
This is just like...
The ult.
My legs are so tired.
I'm so tired.
Please, I'm so tired of dancing.
Let me live.
Alright.
Dance, idol.
Dance.
Oh no, I missed my...
Oh my god.
Please, I'm so tired.
I'm so tired.
I couldn't... What do you mean?
Freeze him!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I'm so close to an ult, though.
I'm so close.
No!
This is so cancer.
This is hell.
This is actually hell.
Why didn't I freeze the... Why did I not freeze him?
My god, Doki.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
This is... I hate this.
This is hell.
This is actual hell.
I hate these fights.
Oh my god.
Who ulted that?
I got them.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of dancing.
Oh my god!
This is so boring.
What the fuck is this?
I don't know what to do either.
No, you were right, by the way.
We should have banned the group.
I should have said so.
Guys.
This is why you don't do the bystanders.
Guys, this is a lesson.
This is a lesson to not do the bystanders.
In fact...
Guys.
And thus, when you know something's wrong, you gotta speak out.
Lesson on speaking out.
You gotta speak out, guys.
Don't let yourself become a bystander.
The price you pay is dancing forever.
You know, I was like, I'll just ban Groot.
And then everyone was like, NAMORIN!
NAMORIN MOON KNIGHT!
I was like, what the fuck, just ban Groot.
But I was like, whatever.
I don't care.
If I'm gonna pop ult first and then you count if you...
Like, what?
I count?
So I don't stack it like I did last game?
Did he say I'm gonna count?
Um, let's... Do you have a mic?
Oh, shit.
Oh no, I have to start counting.
Don't worry, he doesn't know I have a mic.
Jokey.
Oh my god, I'm gonna do a bystander if I didn't learn my lesson.
HAHA!
Okay.
HAHAHAHA!
Stay side.
I'm gonna...
Stop bystanding.
HAHAHAHA!
You're right, guys.
Bum, bum, badoom.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
What is this?
Oh my god, what the fuck is this?
Say something, do something, guys.
Remember.
HAHAHA!
Don't let this become like me.
Time to dance.
This is like one game I've actually wished I... I just wanna stop dancing.
I'm so tired.
HAHAHA!
You see, this is what I'm afraid of in the tournament.
Wow, I lived, bitch!
This is exactly what I'm afraid of.
Do as I say, not as I do.
Bum, bum, badoom.
That's why I hope games... I just hope tournaments are not gonna be like this.
But it might.
Actually, no.
It might not happen again.
Oh.
Bum, bum, badoom.
I'm gonna keep dancing.
I'm gonna dance.
I'm gonna dance forever.
Dance monkey.
HAHAHA!
Alright.
Oh.
I legitimately forgot about this ult.
Nice ult.
Dance monkey, dance.
That's all you're good for.
You just keep dancing until it's never over.
But the thing is, it's never over.
And then you're gonna dance until you graduate and retire.
And then you're gonna live through the fucking aftermath of just dancing.
No dance until it's done.
You'll never be happy because you're just a monkey to the system.
The more you dance, she's losing it.
I'm just... I'm just a monkey.
I have ult soon, I have ult soon, I have ult soon.
It's gonna be so fun.
Okay.
Go!
Dance!
Nice.
Okay, I was a little worried there.
This is hell, this is hell, this is hell, this is hell, this is...
No, I didn't have to ult.
This is hell, this is hell, this is hell.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm okay.
It's okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay now, I'm not crashing out.
I'm not crashing out, I swear.
Does nothing end?
This...
Does this just... Does this just go forever?
Oh, I missed my freeze.
I feel like... I feel like this is a fight that lasts just forever.
Nothing fucking ends.
Oh my god, please.
I'm just... That's all I am.
That's all I am.
Oh, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Please, we gotta touch.
Guys, are we there?
I can't stop.
There we go.
Kill everything.
Go crazy, boys.
How?
How do we kill everything and nothing dies?
Oh no.
That was hell.
That doesn't even matter how much I died.
That was gonna be a great season.
You can rest now, fuck.
That's actually hell.
Nothing stopped.
I feel like everything was continuous.
Nothing ever stopped.
Oh my god.
I felt like nothing ever stopped.
It was just one incredibly long fight.
This is the one time I did not want to keep dancing anymore.
Dancing used to be so fun.
It used to be so fun, guys.
That was the game where I was like, I don't want to dance no more.
Sure.
I just...
Maybe dancing is not as fun as I thought.
Until they sucked all the joy out.
Until I realized...
Until I realized it was not as fun as it used to be.
I used to be that squid game guy.
Where I was hopeful and energetic.
And passionate about it.
And now I'm the second guy.
Now I'm season two.
Where I realized dancing isn't all that cut out to be.
I just want to stop dancing.
I felt like...
She has danced this dance before.
I legitimately felt like I didn't stop.
I was like...
By the time the other support finished the ult cycle.
I got my ult again.
And then I had to keep dancing.
It just didn't stop.
Legitimately, we were just cycling.
I felt like I was dancing every other fight.
I was dancing every other fucking fight.
It was a constant tango.
Oh my god.
I boogied her last boogie.
I was...
Keep dancing.
It's not over yet.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
How long has it been streaming?
Okay.
This might be LG.
I can't.
I can't keep doing it.
Those last two games were actual hell.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back.
Alright.
Are they still fucking queuing?
Holy shit.
They are.
Fuck it.
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Okay, I'm...
I thought...
Something different.
Let them fight their four stack.
No.
I thought, like...
I thought...
He meant, like, we can fight it to the other...
To the...
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Great.
They fight each other.
Thank God.
Four stack versus four stack.
They fucking deserve each other.
Like...
Thank...
Thank fucking God.
Four stack.
Oh, my God.
It's true.
Like, we actually...
I actually...
Dodged them at the exact moment.
That's crazy.
The moment I cancelled the queue...
They matched up against each other.
It's...
Oh, my God.
Literally...
His team...
His team's four stack...
Is fighting against...
That fucked up...
Combo stack.
The moment I clicked cancel...
Holy fuck.
We didn't get to do...
Oh, my God.
I'm so happy.
I'm so fucking happy.
I don't have to go through that shit again.
Oh, my God.
We are saved.
They actually matched against each other.
We are fucked.
Now, they have to go through the cancer that I just went through.
Nice quick reaction.
Thank God.
I'm pretty sure...
Is it...
Are they like...
Were they...
Wait.
Are they...
Four stack...
Is the other team four stacking too?
Because...
Or are they...
Or is it trio?
Oh, that's fucking...
That's why.
Okay.
That makes more sense.
This is why every...
All the high elo players four stack.
Because it's just so easy to win games.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Why they were even more coordinated than I thought they were.
Like...
I thought it was...
I thought it was a three stack.
Because at least they have three randoms.
But they had four professional players.
Basically, it was four pro players together.
That makes much more sense now.
Guys.
I was not gonna win against four pros, guys.
I was...
That's not...
Yeah.
I was...
I was not winning against four pros.
My teams were always like just randoms together.
Yeah.
You had it.
You just didn't believe.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why I'm really scared of the tournament.
I'm really scared of how...
Because I don't...
I know...
Four...
Five of the teams.
That's confirmed.
And there's two teams that I'm scared of.
But there's also twelve teams in total.
So I don't know the other half.
So I'm scared.
It's...
I know the captains.
I know who the captains are.
I know how...
I know ten of the captains.
But they never told me who were the last two captains.
So like...
I hope we get top four.
Because if I have to play like...
If I have to play in a tournament setting and these are...
Well, it'll be easier because we're all coordinated in a team together.
We're all coordinated as a team together this time.
Because this one we have to deal with like...
You know, we have like four other random players.
And which is the same in our other match that we had with them.
And...
And like...
I'm a little scared of...
Of like...
Whatever half...
I know like...
I'm a little scared what the other half of the teams are gonna be like.
So yeah.
That's why I hope we get...
I hope we get top four.
That's my hope.
And I hope...
Also like...
They were like...
We should scrim.
But they never told me what time they are free.
So like...
If I don't hear anything from them...
If I don't hear anything...
From like...
My team...
And like...
By the end of...
By the morning of tomorrow...
I'm just gonna schedule something.
They gotta deal with it.
I'll be like...
I asked!
I gave you guys!
I...
I literally told you guys.
And I said...
You had your chance!
I...
Okay, it might be tough for...
For...
Yeah, you're right.
It might be tough for Kony.
Like...
I asked Kony too!
I'm gonna take things in my own hands.
Exactly.
If they don't show up...
Then it's their reputation...
That they're damaging.
And not mine.
Cause I can be like...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I told them to show up.
But like...
I'm here.
It's their reputation that's on the line.
Not mine.
I'm the responsible one.
Exactly.
Look, I was like...
Hey guys.
I need to know what time you're all free.
And if I don't hear a response...
In...
Within the morning...
I'm scheduling something.
It's too late.
I'm gonna schedule something.
And they gotta deal with it.
If they want that 5k...
Each, by the way...
Each person gets 5k...
If they wanna get that 5k...
I better see some fucking dedication.
Yeah.
First place is like 5k each.
Basically.
But like...
Everybody gets money.
So like...
Even when you lose...
You also get money too.
Yeah.
Scheduling conflict.
The matches for Sage Amslam...
Does not...
I have something...
For when...
I have...
I have to do something.
On one of the days...
For two of the days that the matches are gonna be in.
So like...
I just didn't see the point.
Cause I'm not gonna cancel my thing.
For it.
Like...
Also...
Yeah.
It's just...
Scheduling was just...
It just conflicted with my schedule.
And stuff.
Also, I was only gonna do it if the full...
Brawl Pro team was coming back.
Cause that was like the only thing I really wanna do.
Cause like...
I just really wanna play with Team Brawl Pro.
But literally, only Kony was gonna do it.
Everyone else was busy.
Slime, Brawl Pro, and...
Matt were all busy too.
So it's just like...
Oh well.
You know.
It is what it is.
Yeah.
Like the moon.
I shine in darkness.
All it took was complaining.
Wait, did he complain?
Who am I gonna banish next?
Okay.
I was like, what?
The shame, I loved your Slime stream.
I miss your slime.
I feel like...
Oh.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Who was he?
Who were you?
Who were you, this guy?
I'll remember you.
I'm writing your name down.
You don't follow the crowd.
How dare you.
How dare you not be a fucking sheep.
Alright.
Yippee.
I get to practice more.
Yay.
But who would have thought the other 4-stack is able to coordinate against the...
Oh, the other 4-stack banned Groot.
They're so smart.
They're much more smarter than...
You know, I feel like...
Yeah.
I feel like Kurova would have definitely told him to ban Groot.
They learn from us.
They're so smart.
They banned Groot.
Oh, we're doing it?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Okay.
If only I...
I swear to fucking god.
I swear to god, if they're also gonna...
I swear to god, they're gonna Groot Moonlight.
I swear to god, I'm gonna...
I swear to god, I'm so fucking...
Oh my god, I...
Are we gonna be the problem?
Don't trust them.
I know, I was being sarcastic.
Oh no, I'm scared, guys.
I'm so scared.
Cause that means they're gonna do that too.
I'm so scared, guys.
You'll suck it.
Yes, but I'm scared they're gonna do the same thing.
If we're doing it.
Oh, they are.
They have Namor and Groot.
Oh my god.
No!
It's whoever team has the better combo!
Oh my god.
No!
Oh no, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared, guys.
I...
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna be happy.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
They're dead, they're dead.
Dude, TTK's stack is killing them.
Dude, they are so boring to go against.
I'm just saying, I've never lost to TTK.
I've only won against them.
They are the most boring people of all time.
I'm pretty sure anyone can play Wolverine.
Oh shit.
I have my own whenever, by the way.
Not good, but they didn't do anything.
I'm gonna die, I might die.
I got an ult, I got an ult.
Pick ult, pick ult.
Oh shit.
I had to hide.
We took too long.
I had to grab a pocket.
It's okay.
Thank you.
This is where I die.
Okay.
I don't think we're stalling anymore.
Did they cap?
No, they didn't.
We're still, we're still...
Alright, wait, wait, they used their combo, they used their combo!
Don't need to fear!
Oh, they still have MR.
Oh, that's fucking stupid.
Oh my, guys.
I don't think I like Rivals right now.
I don't think...
Guys, I don't...
I guess unless we bind, we just have to ban group.
We just...
We just have to ban group, guys.
I think...
We just...
We just need to...
We just need to ban group.
We just...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he was on top!
Okay.
This comp is actually so boring.
We can maybe copy Groot and look for Groot ult.
I don't know.
It's so boring.
Guys, I think they have the...
Guys, I think they have the better Groot player, I think.
I really think that we need to go not Madoka.
Madoka's pretty fine.
I don't know.
I just feel like we can't let it fucking go.
I couldn't do anything.
I think we have the better Groot, guys.
Strange one, strange one.
I
hope you're happy!
I hope you're happy now.
Three, two...
Oh, and they have that too.
Oh my god, don't leave point.
We need point.
I hope you're happy now.
Do we have Loki...
We don't have Loki ult.
No, I think this Groot is better than our Groot.
I 100% believe it.
I know we have a Lord Groot, but like...
I don't know.
They have Groot ult and I'm scared.
They should be coming up on their combo though.
We might as well care.
They TP behind.
I knew it!
Why didn't we punch him?!
I fucking knew it!
Oh my god, my brain was so high IQ!
I fucking knew it.
Oh, we don't have TP anymore.
Oh my god.
Mr. Groot, he has Groot.
Don't worry, I'm on the broken character.
It's alright.
Hey, sick freeze though!
Sick freeze!
The game like 10 times easier.
Alright.
Okay.
I think this will be fine.
Sick freeze though.
Sick freeze.
I can play Alistar first, yeah.
Or... you first.
Oh, actually no, me first.
I forgot.
I'm faster.
So I should do it first.
Bum, bum, bum.
I'll play Luna just because she's the best healer right now.
But I'll play other characters.
And also for my team, I have to play Luna for tournament.
Because the other support is going to play Cloak and Dagger.
So I have to play Luna because the support duo is Luna with Cloak and Dagger.
So I'm just practicing more Luna.
Did they copy someone?
Who did they copy though?
No, fuck!
Okay.
Aww.
I have to... I didn't want to.
Okay, we're gonna get ulted here.
Yay!
I'm scared.
Scared, fear, fear.
Fear.
Oh no, please copy me.
Please copy me.
No!
You couldn't copy!
This was the perfect copy moment!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Alright.
It's fine.
This is not fine.
Our group might be dead.
This is so fine.
We're okay.
I have to pop.
Our group is like taking 2 million damage per second.
Alright.
We did it.
We've always been on mag!
No, we just swapped to mag, guys.
Just now.
I'm a little scared.
It's literally 1 HP.
No!
He can just do that?!
He can just fucking walk behind!
Okay.
He can just fucking...
Are you serious?
They can't...
What?!
Where is my copy?!
Will they ever copy?!
I guess I die.
I guess...
Please!
Copy one time!
Oh my god!
What are you...
Okay.
That's fine.
Copy for...
I'm so mad.
I'm legitimately like...
I feel like I've been watching him hold copy for 20...
I swear to god!
I watched him...
Oh my god!
Who are you holding copy for?!
I had to die for no reason several times.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm so okay.
He's like...
And I'm literally...
Are you...
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything is...
Everything is so healthy.
Oh my god.
I have to...
I have to keep using ult as like a...
I can't even use ult to defend.
Like, it's...
It's hell.
It's actually...
Like, I don't know what to do.
It's actual hell.
I...
I feel like I'm trapped.
I'm trapped in this.
I'm actually trapped.
I'm in the Twilight Zone.
I'm actually in the Twilight Zone right now.
Oh my god.
I'm trapped here.
My lowkey actually...
I wanna cry.
I actually wanna cry.
Oh my god.
He's dancing.
He's actually dancing.
I'm so...
Please.
Dance on the...
Please don't let him kill me.
Please.
Oh my god.
I don't have to waste my ult.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna waste it.
Restrain yourself, Doki!
Oh my god.
There you go.
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
I restrained myself.
We had our first group combo?!
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
That was our first combo.
That was my first combo.
Oh my god.
You hear Luna at 63.
TP.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I'm so calm.
It's Groot.
Moon Knight.
That's the combo.
But we literally used it once.
He saved the copy for this moment.
We'll hit the first one.
Oh my god.
I'm 4% off.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Our Loki, like, fell.
I don't know if I accidentally...
I think it was me, though.
Not gonna lie.
I think I accidentally...
What the fuck happened?!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We did a combo!
I'm so proud of you guys.
I'm so proud.
You did it, Groot.
Oh no, they're gonna do it, too.
They're gonna do the same thing.
Now.
Not in my stu-
Oh, I'm on it.
I'm on it.
I got in.
Okay, everyone is dead.
Okay.
I don't know why.
Alright.
That's very unfortunate.
No, I did it!
I had to- Yeah, okay.
They're separated, but I had to save my tanks.
I ulted for my tanks.
My tanks live.
So, like...
Hey, guys.
All I'm saying is that I kept my tanks alive.
And I...
I did my mission.
But I won.
Alright, there you go.
Wait, they double support.
Wait, no.
Please.
I'm trying.
Oh, that's huge.
That's huge.
That's not huge anymore.
Our Loki doesn't use it defensively.
Okay.
Our Loki...
Ults aggressively.
And he can't do that.
He has to ult defensively.
Because I'm ulting to keep our tanks alive.
And, like, we need a defensive ult.
Yeah, our Loki ults have been, like, really weird.
Like, his ult is, like...
Don't worry, he's brooding.
Did he do it?
He did.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay, we have a bigger trade.
What?
Okay.
Not gonna lie, I am not a big fan of these ults.
Like, this is how you're supposed to ult Loki dead.
But this is actually how you're supposed to...
This is how you're supposed to ult these.
He's dead, but, like, you know, let's see.
It's the thought that counts, though.
Okay, I know the loss is not my fault, though.
The loss is not my fault, guys.
It's not my fault.
Oh, he's dead.
It's actually... I've done my job.
Okay, okay, it's... Oh my god, it's been three hours.
Do I keep... Alright.
What's the maximum amount to get the drops, guys?
Guys, I de-ranked.
It's fine.
I can get it back.
Can't end on a loss, that's so true.
Four hours?
I forgot the four hours.
Goddamn.
Okay, I'll do one more hour.
I'll do one more hour to get... I'm back where I started.
That's fine.
I'll do one more hour for the hella skin.
I'm gonna avoid this Loki.
That Loki actually pissed me off.
That Loki made me so... Also, this Groot, too.
This Groot as well.
They've both made me mad.
Wait, are they... Are they still... Oh, they're in-game.
Okay.
Did they win?
I'm gonna check.
Oh, I can't... I can't download them.
Wait.
Right.
Does that hit it?
Alright.
I wanna know if they won.
Oh, they did!
Nice.
See, guys?
They banned Groot.
I wish we were smart enough for that.
LOL
Our Groot never got a combo off.
Actually.
Our Groot got the combo off one time and that was it.
Oh my god.
We just have to... We have to ban Groot.
If we don't ban Groot...
Ban Groot, I will actually...
I will actually just leave the game.
LOL
It's like...
It's like... Sorry.
It's like hella...
It's like hella Hawkeye again.
But worse.
It's so much worse.
It's so much worse than hella Hawkeye.
I think like...
Groot...
Groot, Moon Knight, and Amour is so fucking...
More oppressive than hella Hawkeye.
It's actually so much more oppressive.
Because I feel like you can't do anything.
You can counter hella Hawkeye with positioning.
And... With positioning and like...
But it's like... It's like...
Whoever has a better Groot player wins the fucking game.
It's... Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't deal with that shit again.
I can't deal with having the... Whoever has the better Groot.
That shit was terrible.
Leaves game for not banning Groot.
I will fucking... I will leave the game if we don't...
You think I'm joking?
I will actually leave the game if we don't ban Groot.
We are... No, you don't get that privilege.
Wait, he's back?
I avoided him!
I'm banning Groot.
I don't...
I avoided him.
I fucking...
Oh no.
I actually avoid stream sniping.
He's back.
Wait, I don't know if it's because...
Yeah, this guy is stream sniping me.
Oh, I was already in queue.
Oh my god.
Little bitch.
Fuck off, Groot.
That's funny that he thinks I'm a one trick.
He's banning Luna.
That's silly.
I literally play everything else.
Oh, he... Wait, did he actually leave?
He dodged?
My goat has crash coming back.
Wait, is he actually...
Wait, is he actually gonna throw?
I can't tell.
Wait.
Gomez has connection with death if he throws.
Hahaha.
The ring guy left.
No, I know, but he said he's coming back though.
No, apparently Gomez says stream sniping is bannable.
Apparently.
But they have to be like super obvious about it.
Yeah, they'd be like super fucking obvious that you're stream sniping.
What's the deal with this Groot?
He just got diffed by the enemy Groot.
That's it.
And like, you get diffed.
No, Luna's a very common ban.
It's a very common ban because Luna is...
Luna makes the game like unplayable for like 12 seconds and people hate that, which is understandable.
It's very understandable to not want to play.
I'm solo healing!
People need to remember, but people don't.
People don't remember that I'm solo healing.
Hahaha.
Like, what can I do?
I'm literally solo healing.
Oh, he's back.
He's back.
I completely forgot you were gone, to be honest.
Oh, he's here now.
Yippee!
Alright.
Alright, let's see how this is gonna go.
Now that we have the second healer.
People forgot I was solo healing.
Everyone was pushing as if we had a second healer.
It was crazy.
It was actually... It was very impressive.
Oh my god.
They'll be fine, right?
Will they be fine?
They'll be so healthy.
I think they'll be really healthy right now.
Wait, where's my strange?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Um... Do they have... No, cloak.
I'll come out here.
Alright.
That's right!
I got it up too!
That's... Oh my god.
I hate this.
Oh my god.
Okay, mine's longer too.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna throw this around and hope that...
I... I don't know.
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I'm gonna play here.
Nice.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna play here.
Oh my god.
This is... Thank god.
This Loki actually knows how to play Loki.
Thank fucking god.
I'm so happy.
I just went through pure hell.
I went through... I went through pure hell.
Okay, they have the moon though.
They have the moon.
They have the moon right now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
He's so good.
He's so okay.
I blind you!
I blind you and I'm gonna fucking suck!
That's right!
Oh shit.
You know what?
Fuck it.
We don't have to do this.
I'm gonna TP back.
Literally, we're so... We don't have to use my ult.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Alright, let's go in.
You all die now.
You all die!
Wait, what?
Okay, I guess we get the free push.
Guys, look.
I really wanted to live.
It's not a waste of my ult because we stagger them.
Guys, look at that.
Look at this stagger.
Guys, look at this stagger.
Right here.
That's right.
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Guys, there's a Venom on cart.
What the fuck?
He didn't even say anything!
He said nothing!
What the fuck?
I don't understand.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why are people still contesting?
I like how the Venom said nothing.
I mean, the Loki said nothing.
That's so silly though.
I can't believe he said nothing.
Bro, we all broke!
We got the Venom on.
Venom one.
Why was he... He was like, I can 1v1.
What is a 1v1?
That's true.
That's so true.
He was like, why you ruin my 1v1?
Bro, I got this.
I fucking got it.
Did he hit him?
I don't think he hit him.
I have to use my ult now.
Now it's my ult.
Oh my god.
That's four ults.
Holy shit.
How many ults was that?
Oh my god.
That was like four ults on each team.
That's crazy.
That's a lot of ults to be fair.
That's actually a lot of ults.
I was not expecting four different ults.
Oh wait, 30 seconds.
That's not good.
We got body blocked in.
This is the last fight.
We lost that?
There was four fucking ults, guys.
It was a lot of ults, guys.
You don't understand.
Yeah, it was.
It was fucking crazy.
That's not all.
It was... yeah.
I don't know if I can build my ult soon.
My ult is going to take a while to build.
Just live.
Wow, that sounds so easy, guys.
Just live, 4Head.
Wait, nobody is on the cart.
Okay, I need to make sure Super doesn't fucking die.
That's what I gotta make sure.
And also him too.
I'm like close to ult, but...
I need to build my ult here.
Come fast.
Nice, I got it.
I counter ult, though.
I got mooned.
I actually got mooned.
It happened so fast.
Like, what happened?
I got mooned.
I got mooned, guys.
There was nothing I could do.
That moon hit me like a hurricane.
Oh, no.
Please don't die.
I'm sending it in.
I'm going in.
No!
The mind game.
The stupid mind game.
The stupid fucking mind game.
I took my gamble.
Oh, my god.
I gambled and it didn't work.
I fucking risked my life for that gamble.
He actually... Oh, my god.
I need to remember that.
I need to remember.
Do not ult.
Do not ult when he has it.
Do not do it, Doki.
Don't do it again.
Oh, no.
I'm trying to help you.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't do anything.
I can't live.
So, no.
They have...
Why can't... Why can't... I don't know.
You know what's not fair?
Why can't their Cloak get to live against a Magneto ult and then I can't?
I need to get back into the headspace of like... I can't ult until this stupid Magneto does his spear.
Fucking always.
It's prep.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Do they play Hulk?
Does Cloak have escape?
Yeah, she does.
This ability.
But I can't do it in time.
I couldn't do it in time because I got mooned.
It was like... I got mooned so I couldn't get it out in time.
And by the time I got... Because I was like... Because if I do it... Because if I try to do it...
In the middle of a moon, I die because the casting is too fast.
The moon casting is so fast that like if I do this... If I do the moon ability in the middle of a moon ult, I die.
You can't get the cheesy kills off no more.
So I have to be very careful.
So I didn't realize I lived a moon.
I've never seen Gomez play fucking Hulk before so this is going to be interesting.
Oh, now the Cloak gets to live for... THE CLOAK GETS TO LIVE FOR FREE?!
This is so bullshit.
This is actually so bullshit.
I'm so sad.
The Cloak actually... The Cloak gets to live for free.
I'm so sad now.
I'm so sad.
What am I supposed to do now?
I am so sad.
Oh, they're running triple support?
Oh my god, they're desperate.
They really want to win.
Oh my god, that's when you know.
That's when you fucking know.
Oh my god, okay.
Please shoot the Ankh.
I can't shoot the Ankh.
Please shoot the Ankh for me.
Oh my god.
I can't... I can't use it.
Oh, fuck you.
Oh my god.
Oh, they don't... They don't Magneto on my Loki?!
I don't... I'm so mad.
I'm... I'm so... Oh, so when my Loki Mag ults, they don't Magneto.
But when I ult, they do.
Like,
okay.
Okay.
Okay, I can't.
I lost my ult.
I actually lost my ult.
I'm playing like shit right now.
No, I'm playing like fucking garbage right now.
I'm sorry.
I'm a little tilted.
I'm a little tilted right now.
I'm playing like fucking garbage on Cloak.
I'm just... I'm just sad that, like, it's just not fair.
I don't understand.
Every time I ult, I get hit by Magneto.
I'm okay.
I'm right here.
They have Magneto, but I won't say anything.
Wait, I Cloaked.
I Cloaked it.
Wait, what?
Did it not work?
I Cloaked it.
Okay, I actually Cloaked it.
What?
Our Cloak ult stayed though.
I actually... I thought I Cloaked him.
Okay, but I have my Cloak ult for free now.
I'm so happy.
Now he gets...
No, he kept the Cloak ult.
I saw it still on the floor, which was weird.
I didn't expect... I thought we'd lose it.
Alright.
Alright, this is it.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
Alright, we fight on point.
Wait, how did our guy die?
Wait, did he solo ult him?
Oh no, not disappear.
Wait, what?
Where did everybody go?
Why did we all go backwards?
Wait, what?
They're all just... Okay.
We all went backwards.
Alright.
Are we touching or not though?
I don't think we are.
I don't think we can.
Oh, we can't even touch.
Yeah, I don't think so either.
I was like, everybody just disappeared.
The moment I heard disappear, they all... they all disappeared.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, it like... my entire team actually went...
I don't know if that hits the range, but I did it for the sake of it.
I did it for the fun of it.
I don't know.
I'm a little worried right now.
I'm a little bit worried right now because...
Alright, I dodged it.
I think.
I think it was dodged.
Is my team okay right now?
Because I don't know if he is.
I don't know if my team is okay right now.
They have Magneto and I'm a little afraid.
I'm like actual fear right now.
Guys, guys, guys, we need a touch.
Guys, guys, we need a touch.
Guys, what are we doing?
Guys, guys, guys, guys, what was happening?
Oh,
we double support ulted.
That's not good.
That's actually not good.
Wait, what?
Okay, guys, okay.
Well,
shit.
Oh my god, that's funny because this guy doesn't talk either.
Okay, that team's sold.
That's funny because he's a...
Oh wait, no, there's a lot of hate watchers.
That's funny.
Imagine flaming and then the chat is against him.
Alright.
That's fucking hilarious.
There you go.
Bro sucks and wants to blame me.
The last game he fucked me was so bad.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he was... yeah.
That's silly.
What a silly guy.
I already avoided him.
It's because we didn't stop Q to avoid.
What a silly guy.
Imagine being... no, I like hate watchers because I can do this.
I can run a one minute ad.
That's why a lot of streamers encourage hate watching.
Because they can just run ads in front of the hate watchers.
Oh yeah, by the way, I always forget to say this before the stream.
Oh yeah, if you want to dodge the subscribe...
Not even hate... I mean that's the best part about people who hate watch people.
Because I don't know a lot of hate watchers.
I don't have a lot of stream snipers.
And it's also crazy the amount of ego you have to say that on a stream.
Because if anything, you're just getting hate on yourself even more.
Because that just invites people to fuck with you.
That's crazy.
And you have yourself to blame if you know you're doing bad and you watch the stream.
You have yourself to blame.
Because I don't watch streams if I knew I was bad on.
I don't watch streams of a person that's streaming that I know I did fucking terrible at.
Because I know I played bad.
That game I played pretty bad.
Because I was just like... I was tilted.
Because I was so tilted at the enemy Meganito.
I just hate the mind games.
The mind games...
Like... The mind games... I fucking hate it.
He didn't even kill the fucking Cloak and Dagger once with his Meganito.
But I kept... The Meganito killed me and the Loki several times.
Are you... I fucking...
I'm done after this game.
These Q's are cursed.
I'm actually done after this game.
These Q's are way too cursed.
I might play off stream.
I'm really...
Tired of it.
I'm gonna make a statement here, okay?
If one of you dodge... If one of you dodge...
I'm done.
With the snipers.
This is... This game is just... Horrible.
This is so horrible.
Oh my god.
No, this is...
We're stacking.
Why did we not ban Groot?
You can get your rank back.
Wait, really?
Oh my god, he actually did it.
Wait, he actually did it.
Oh my god.
I didn't expect it.
That wild man.
I fucking... I was gonna ban Groot anyway.
That fucking wild man.
If he looks back... Okay, I'll actually pay him.
If he looks back...
If he looks back, that's like he's silly.
Oh yeah, no.
The enemy team is four stacking.
The enemy team is...
Four stacking.
So like, it's just not fun if you don't have a...
It's only fun if it's...
It's only fun if it's like four stack against four stack.
Because then it's like super coordinated.
Matches are much more... It's better.
But like...
I don't know.
It's not fun when it's like four stack versus random.
It's only fun when it's four stack versus four stack.
So like, I wouldn't mind if I'm in a four stack and I'm fighting them.
Because it's much more coordinated.
Because... It's because I'm not.
It's not fun.
And we have diamonds on our team.
We have diamonds.
No, this game is going to cancel after a minute.
It's going to cancel.
How much more?
I have 30 more minutes.
You guys just want to chat for 30 minutes?
Okay, do that.
Wait, actually I can be a Marvel rival.
Hello.
I think late night sniping is more cringe.
Because it's easier.
It's easier to snipe late at night.
Because there's less people playing.
But I want you guys to have your drops.
20 more seconds.
Yippee.
Fucking chill.
Yippee drops.
Yippee.
I'm going to play a bit off stream.
Because I do want to practice.
I feel like I didn't get enough practice.
Because I'm just like...
Elo terrorized right now.
I mean...
I feel like I'm getting elo terrorized.
So I'm not practicing as much.
I just want to get better.
Yippee.
Okay.
I'm done.
Alright.
I'm going to talk to chat.
Um.
Done.
I'm going to talk to chat.
For 30 minutes.
So they can get drops.
Uh.
Too much sniping.
Alright.
Playing against...
4 stacks.
Okay.
I don't mind if I have my own 4 stack.
But like, I'm fucking...
Alright.
It's chatting time.
Okay.
Chatting so you guys get drops.
Chatting...
So...
You guys...
Get drops.
I think like, at first we weren't getting sniped.
Because I just started my stream.
But...
As the night goes on...
It gets more and more obvious.
It just...
Like...
Because in the beginning...
In the beginning...
Things were a lot easier.
Because I felt so free.
To do whatever the fuck I want.
In the beginning.
And then...
As like...
Time...
It dragged on...
More and more.
I realized...
I realized things are...
Things were not going so well.
After that.
I think it was...
People noticed I was online too.
Because...
I...
You know, when I did the...
People noticed that...
I was online.
And it was just...
It was a little cringe.
Not gonna lie.
I do like...
Still like this game.
I don't find delay really fun.
I think like...
I think at this point...
I think it's solo...
I don't know.
I'm worried about solo queuing now.
Like...
It's...
It's also more...
It's also easier to...
Snipe late at night.
Because there's less people queuing.
So like...
There's not a lot of people that's high elo.
And because there's not a lot of people that's high elo.
You tend to match up.
You tend to match up with the same people.
Over and over again.
So...
So like...
It's easier to...
It's easier to like...
Get the person you want to play with.
Or against.
But like...
If I'm playing primetime.
Because like...
If I'm playing like...
On...
You know, earlier.
It's a lot more...
Difficult.
GM is not high elo.
I'm...
I...
I was...
I was at GM 1.
And then...
Things went downhill.
It's still high elo.
It's top of 100.
GM 1 is still top of...
Like, it's like top of 100.
Yeah.
And...
Yeah, so like...
I was...
It was...
It was rough.
It was so rough.
So that's why I was like...
Oh my god.
I was like...
I can't do this anymore.
This is too rough for me.
This is too rough.
And I felt like I wasn't getting...
Enough practice.
Going in.
Because I just wanted to practice for the tournament.
I just want to get better for...
For the tournament on Saturday.
So yeah.
I might practice...
I want to practice more off stream though.
I'm not going to play for too long.
I just want to...
I used to solo queue.
But like...
I don't do it on stream anymore.
Because like...
People were purposely...
Queue sniping me.
When I was streaming on Twitch.
I did it on YouTube.
Because like...
Nobody knew I existed on solo...
Nobody knew I existed on YouTube.
So I could get away solo queuing.
But now that I'm on Twitch.
I can't get away with it anymore.
So...
So like...
It's just...
Better for my mental.
To not solo queue.
If I'm streaming on Twitch.
Shouldn't I practice my other support?
She's gold right now.
Is she gold?
I mean she has to be maximum plat.
I feel better if I practice...
I don't feel like I'm going to get much practice.
In gold plat elo.
I feel like it'd be better.
If I practice with her in a scrim.
Because...
I don't think I'm going to get much practice.
Much practice doing gold plat lobbies.
Because it's very easy.
Yeah.
And I just want to practice what I'm playing for in the tournament.
Because she's going to play Cloak and Dagger.
And I really don't want to play Cloak and Dagger.
I don't want to play Cloak and Dagger right now.
Because I'm not...
I don't need to...
I don't need to like...
Play her right now.
Hope games can...
I hope so too.
I just want to practice Luna.
I just want to practice her more and...
Practice her freezes and stuff.
Fistful, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
And thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I think this has been my roughest ranked session on stream.
This has definitely been my roughest ranked session.
But I also think that everyone is now...
I was at a point where everyone...
I kept bumping into the stackers.
Billy, thank you for the gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Nexy, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
I really appreciate it.
No, I'm pretty sure the...
I saw a lot of teams.
I saw a lot of teams that were running...
That are practicing Groot and Moon Knight.
In general.
Some teams have started streaming their practices.
Some teams started streaming their practices.
And they were basically practicing Groot and Moon Knight.
I hope my...
I honestly...
I'm gonna ban Groot.
I think.
I can't.
I cannot deal with...
That combo is so oppressive.
It's just not fun.
That's the only team comp...
That legitimately just don't have fun playing against.
I love Marble Rivals.
But that actually kills my...
It actually kills my enjoyment of Marble Rivals.
Because there's no counterplay.
It just sucks when there's no counterplay.
I wish there was.
If there was at least one counterplay...
I'd be happy.
But there isn't.
The only counterplay is like...
We split up.
And I'm like, what the...
What kind of counterplay is that?
Just split up everyone.
Just split up.
What kind of counterplay is that?
Aren't they people that are gifting a tier 1 sub?
No, it doesn't.
It doesn't absorb it.
It's just not...
It's just one count...
Oh my god.
Let them kill us one by one instead.
Just split up everyone.
Split up gang.
Or maybe...
I hope maybe.
I hope maybe the new heroes...
The new heroes will...
Have some sort of counterplay to it.
Maybe...
Maybe Professor Xavier can fucking kill Groot with his mind.
I don't know.
Maybe his ult is just that he stops...
Like he just stops him from ulting.
Nerf the Groot walls.
I don't know.
It's so...
It's just...
I wish it was less oppressive.
That's for sure.
I don't really care about losing ELO.
Because like...
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this.
But...
There's 85 days of the season.
So I like...
I don't care.
But I'm not getting enough practice.
Like there's 85 days.
There's...
Uh...
So yeah.
It's like...
There's way too many days to play this game.
So like...
It doesn't...
It really...
I don't know.
I don't think seasons should be this long.
I feel like 85 days is way too fucking long.
Um...
Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like...
One and a half is good.
One and a half or two.
Um...
Three months is way too...
No.
Three months is way too long.
Especially for like...
Because like...
If you want to be on the leaderboards.
You just got...
You have to play.
You can't stop playing.
That's the thing.
You literally...
If you stop...
I didn't play for a day and a half.
And I dropped 150 points.
Like, I dropped 150 placements.
Um...
Because I didn't play for...
Not even a day and a half.
It was like almost two days.
I didn't play for almost two days.
No, a day and a half.
And I dropped 150 placements.
And...
Um...
And like...
I can't play every day.
I have...
I have so much more responsibilities.
This month...
Next month, I'll be really busy.
I'll be really busy next month.
And then...
This month, too.
Because I need a...
I need a plan.
I have so much stuff going on behind the scenes.
So...
I just don't have a lot of time to play.
I don't know.
I heard that...
I'm not sure if it's fully confirmed.
But like...
I asked some pros to ask the devs.
And they said there's no plans currently to have a leaderboard record.
Um...
For...
Uh...
For Season 1.
So I'm like, what's the point?
LOL
Like, it's gonna be on a website.
Who the fuck looks up our website?
Like, I'd rather be able to see the leaderboard.
Um...
I'd rather...
We'd be able to see the leaderboard, like...
Um...
On the...
In the game.
So I'm like...
I don't know.
I think that's so stupid.
That really is.
Um...
I don't understand, too.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why we can't look at the history of...
Uh...
The history of, like, past...
Like, of, like...
You know, previous Top 500s.
Cause I feel like...
It's just so easy to implement in general.
And, like...
I feel like that's the biggest reason to...
Uh...
Have it...
In the game.
Cause every game has that.
Like...
Okay, except for Apex.
But...
Apex, at least the badges are much more worth it.
And the badges say what rank you were.
At least, like, Apex badges.
You can see what rank you are.
And you get to have, like...
You know, your badge is not fucking tiny as hell.
Like, the size of a fucking ant.
Like...
At least...
At least the badge is not the size of an ant.
And, like...
Um...
Overwatch has...
Yeah.
Overwatch has the public leaderboards.
Which I could, like, flex and be like...
Hey, guys.
Look at this.
Look.
This is where...
This is where I have...
This is my rank right here.
This is me on the leaderboard.
That's right.
I didn't even get a screenshot where I ended.
I know you guys did.
But, like, I was sleeping.
Cause I didn't know that...
Like, you see this right here?
That's my top 500 badge.
If you guys are curious.
Like...
That's what it is.
Oh, wait.
You guys don't see it.
You see that here?
That's my top 500 badge.
That gold thing right here?
And that's the only way you know I was top 500.
It's right here.
It's...
It's this.
It's this here.
So, I'm like...
I'm like, what's the point?
What's the point?
I hope they have a...
I hope they have, like, a...
I don't know.
I hope they implement it.
If they do implement it in Season 1, then maybe I'll think about it.
But for now, I don't really care too much.
I don't really care too much about the leaderboard.
I just wanna get better.
I legitimately just wanna get better at the game.
For rivals, because I like being a good player.
And, like, I like improving and stuff.
I feel like it's so hard to improve when you have, like, a target on your back.
Now...
Now I know how xQc felt when...
Oh my god.
Bro.
But no one's getting paid.
I'm pretty sure nobody's getting...
None of the fucking snipers are getting paid.
It's just hate.
At least get...
At least I...
I wish the snipers got paid.
Like...
Like, that's not fair.
xQc snipers get paid?
Why can't my snipers get paid?
That's not fair.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
So what happened to xQc was that...
Was that...
Basically...
They...
Chatters were paying players in...
Chatters were paying snipers...
Or, like, players in Marvel Rivals...
To purposely queue snipe xQc at one point.
And, like, either throw his games or, like...
Try extremely hard against him.
Or, like, get on a smurf account to, like...
To, like, purposely, like...
Fuck with his games or, like...
Or, like...
Make sure he lose and stuff.
So, it was, like, it's crazy.
And...
But at least they got paid!
At least...
Guys, if you're gonna snipe me, get paid.
I hope you guys get paid for it.
I hope...
So you don't...
I really hope you guys get paid for it.
Because, like, that makes me feel a lot better.
You know?
That makes me feel...
Because at least I'm making money running ads.
Like...
At least...
At least I...
At least I got money running...
Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
Okay, no.
That's all I want for you guys.
I hope you guys get paid.
Because then it would mean so much more.
It would mean so much more.
I only...
Exactly!
I only want hired assassins!
If you're gonna try...
If you're gonna target me.
I only want people who get hired to kill me.
Or throw my games.
This has been the roughest session.
This has been.
This is why...
I would've gotten off earlier.
But I decided to...
To...
Do it for free.
I wanted to get off earlier.
But I decided to stay longer.
Because I heard you guys...
I know you guys wanted...
There's the drops.
And like 4 hours is apparently the max.
So like...
I'm sorry if you guys watch the stream...
You know what?
Okay.
I'll stop at 4 hours.
But let the ending screen play.
For like an extra 5 minutes.
So like...
If you came in 5 minutes late.
I'm sorry.
Like...
I'm so sorry.
I guess you guys are watching.
I'm streaming.
Wait, when did drops end?
Chat?
Like...
When does the drops end?
If I came in...
Oh, it's 26.
Fucking...
Goodbye.
I'll be streaming...
Oh my god.
I should've read when it ends.
I could've ended earlier.
Oh my god.
I will be streaming on Twitch on Saturday, guys.
Goodbye, everybody.